How and we begin the Joe Rogan
experience podcast is brought to you by
the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the flashlight
and entering the code name,
Rogan,
you'll get 15 percent off the number one
sex toy for men.
It's a fucking solid product and we
stand behind it.
We were also brought in front of a jail.
What kind of voice?
Like fucking are you doing it?
Putting it in your ass,
not doing it wrong.
Am I doing it wrong?
Are you sure I'm doing it wrong?
Well,
even doing it wrong,
I forgot about the lid for people like
been doing it wrong.
It feels so right.
I'm sure someone must have used the
flashlight that way.
Yeah,
I mean I've seen some giant things that
people say like a human flesh repeat.
It's like a big circle of guys,
like half of them are fucking and half
of them are slit up another dude's ass.
A dude had his foot up a dude's ass all
the way up to the ankle.
Is that just for shock value,
like just meet.com
or was that more like a,
I don't know,
man.
You gotta wonder what the motivation
behind anybody wanting to take that
picture or see that picture,
you know,
like,
oh,
whose,
whose medical?
Oh Fuck,
wait,
Tom,
go get the camera,
get the camera.
Does it feel good for your toes or does
it feel good for his ass?
Who's happy here?
Who's happy in this moment?
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com.
Makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement.
Uh,
as I say with all these nootropics and
different things that are cognitive
enhancing supplements,
do some research.
If you're interested in this stuff,
don't just buy Alpha brain.
Please go and Google nootropics and read
some articles.
It's very fascinating.
There's a bunch of different.
They have a bunch of proprietary blends
at a bunch of other companies have that
are great as well.
You know,
just go look and try some stuff out,
read some things on it.
Some things will react well with you.
Somethings won't if you like a Alpha
brain,
but you think it's too expensive.
This is what I want you to do.
I want you to go to the ingredients list
and copy it,
shows you the exact dose,
copy it by the shit and bulk and put it
together yourself.
And here's the thing.
If you buy it and it doesn't work and
you don't like it,
it's 100 percent money back guarantee.
We try to make this as easy as possible.
There's no other way to make it as clear
as possible that I am much more
concerned with you not feeling ripped
off than I am with making money.
So I think it's a real product.
I like it.
I enjoy it.
It's good.
It works for me.
Alpha brain gives me like,
like a nice little peppy feeling.
Um,
I don't know what the fuck's going on
with it.
I don't know what it does,
but that stuff's a lot of people from
taking from taking drugs.
Well,
some people like to like,
well it might not work.
I'm going to be out $400 or whatever it
is.
And I'm like,
I don't want to take a chance on
something.
Might not work if I get some guarantee
that'd be,
that'd be pretty good.
We like drugs.
You mean?
What do you mean?
Like any sort of like,
I don't know,
enhancers or like,
or like whatever you need for whatever
else.
I don't know.
What drugs do people take a while?
This is nothing like a drug though.
None of these things.
I mean,
the only thing that would be close is
the new mood,
the five htp supplement,
which is like a serotonin booster.
But even that it would be like the
subtlest of smiles that permeates your
brain,
you know?
Have you ever used five htp?
Didn't do much for me.
Didn't do we,
you taking the Neal Brennan size doses?
Uh,
I was taking a lot.
I thought.
Yeah.
He said he just goes over the he
whatever the fucking recommended da is
he.
Jack said and he just goes nuts.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
well I thought it was really fascinating
that he said that his doctor who had him
on some sort of an antidepressant,
she told him to get off the five htp
because it was essentially like taking
to antidepressants.
There's something where it can react
really badly with ssrs.
Yeah.
Um,
but that's like happened.
Hundred precedence of that are Ssri,
but it can,
it can cause you some weird overdose.
What is the SSRI?
What is the actual name for that?
It's like serotonin something
reinhibitor ads or delete serotonin.
Well,
um,
I've heard,
uh,
there's also Brian,
you read something about the dangers of
five htp online,
right?
What the fuck was that about?
Somebody sent me this because of
yesterday's podcast where I've been
talking about my arm,
which we've talked to the doctor and he
said it's probably from podcasting.
Okay.
Practicing.
And then he made that song all about how
weak I was.
I know he,
there was a,
hold on,
get to it.
It,
there was somebody set that on a web md
that five htp might be unsafe and not to
take it because people who.
There's been reports that people who are
taking it are getting a serious
condition with extreme muscle tenderness
called Myalgia and blood abnorm nor
modalities.
One of those words.
And uh,
and so,
uh,
said that you shouldn't take it into
thinking it's a contaminant.
And and some five htp products and that,
um,
oh.
So it's not five htp,
it's something that's contaminated.
So it pretty much starts like sour milk
going around.
Oh Wow.
So this is our month is giving people
muscle soreness,
muscle soreness out of nowhere.
And we're to,
we'll get to the bottom of that.
I'll find out what the fuck that is.
So if that's the case,
you know,
pay attention to that folks obviously
don't by chefs in Mexico I've already
talked to,
I've already talked about a mile and
five ht little too cheap.
Looking through it.
Yeah.
I've already talked to Aubrey about it,
about it
from a on it labs and he says not to
worry about it,
that,
that they test it like three times their
own labs.
Test it like three times to make sure,
you know,
that's all good.
But he said he just,
he'll look into it more,
but that's what he,
that's what he.
So it's some cheap company.
Yeah.
It's like cheap company,
five htp,
you know,
like when you're at the store,
like you're at the cvs and you see like,
oh there's this one for $2,
you know,
and
that's good to know.
Okay.
We also have on this list,
alphabet doesn't have that.
Anyway,
this is a new mood which is the five htp
tryptophan supplement.
I like it.
I've been taking it.
But yeah,
I would,
I would definitely consider looking into
what the,
whatever the fuck that's our role is
about because that's
in my honest opinion,
I think the doctors,
right?
Like in my honest,
I mean somebody just said that to me and
that's why obviously you're moving your
arm and it's like the vector raptor
because I have to kind of.
It's almost,
what's that shit called?
Barbers get a lot from carpal tunnel.
Carpal tunnel.
It's almost never.
Also secretary is get a lot.
What else?
What other woman were like?
Podcasting,
too much don't to take days off.
Man.
Icer,
icer elbow.
That's ridiculous.
You're falling apart.
Falling apart.
Crazy.
Anyway.
Well,
like we said with a one
on it,
if you don't like it,
don't buy it and if you,
if you're interested,
go look,
I'll all the other different things that
are available online,
but if you want to buy Alpha brain,
it's available on it.com,
o n n I t,
we also have two different mushroom
supplements.
One's called shroom tech sport and
that's a,
a one for extreme endurance exercises.
Like if you're a person who likes to do
like crossfit or shit like that,
and if you do Jujitsu or you do an mma,
this shroom tech sport is awesome.
It's a quarter's eps,
mushroom and 12 supplement.
It's great for energy.
Like,
um,
they,
the Chinese Olympic team was the first
to start using it like the nineties.
Apparently it's like a mushroom that
enhances your body's ability to absorb
air.
Really?
Yeah.
You were in high altitudes,
like they noticed that cattle were
eating these mushrooms and then they
were much more lively so people started
experimenting with them.
I thought it was a mushroom pills.
You thought it was talking about
bill must have those natural mushrooms
because silicide Oh,
that's done mushrooms.
That's dangerous.
I don't know.
My friends,
my friends taken them and I was like,
they're just great man.
You don't get the upset stomach.
No.
Everything else was saying it's like thc
pills,
but it feel like then you're not working
for it as part of the mushroom
experiences.
If you're going to get the dry,
the gifts,
you can eat that shitty body of it.
I'd have to try it.
I don't know where it gets them.
This is nothing like that.
This is just for endurance and there's
another one for immune scald.
Trim Tech Immune,
which is a great one.
It's a really interesting way it works
is we explain.
Explained to me is there's this mushroom
and when your body detects it,
your body thinks that it's some sort of.
It might be a bug,
like might be a cold or something like
that,
so your immune system fires up for a
fight that never comes.
Really?
Yeah.
So this mushroom somewhere,
now that tricks your body into thinking
it's going to be attacked,
but nothing happens and so your immune
system fights,
it,
pumps up,
it pumps up for a fight and there's no
fight.
So it really helps your immune system
ward off colds quicker.
Yeah,
it's.
I believe in.
I think here's something to look into to
folks is probiotics I think are very
important.
Something that a lot of people
know.
Probiotics are live cultures.
It's like acidophilus or Kombucha is my
favorite.
I drink that Kombucha Shit.
A drink that tea every day.
I really firmly believe it keeps you
from getting sick.
Oxidants,
antioxidants.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they are.
This is a little different though.
This is a live culture.
Live culture is actually living things.
It's an organism you're taking into your
body that actually fights off bad shit.
It's kind of crazy,
but it works.
This organism works symbiotically with
your body.
Does I don't know mushrooms or is that
just like,
no,
no.
It's different.
You know,
some of them will fucking kill you and
there's mushrooms.
You fuck up and eat the wrong ones.
You'll have instant liver failure,
like there's some serious failure
mushrooms out there and somebody had to
find that out,
man.
Somebody had to eat those things and
then they had like everybody stand and
watch them and then 20 minutes later
he's fucking black skinned and foaming
at the mouth and his whole body spasming
and you're like,
okay,
now we know that mushroom is bad,
don't fucking eat that.
And they had to know this by the way,
back when there was no books.
No,
write it down.
You remember how honeysuckles we're okay
to eat.
But that other barrier weren't what?
Remember honeysuckles.
Oh yeah.
No,
I don't pull the tick them off.
I was looking for them recently.
Was the one drop of honey.
Really?
Yeah.
I've been actually looking for.
They don't have those out here in Los
Angeles today because I thought I saw
one the other day and I'm like,
but I didn't actually got it and see if
it was one.
I think they have them somewhere,
but don a lot.
Definitely.
I miss those other great when you're
biking around,
but you just knew which ones were fine
with the kinkiness o n n I t.com,
and enter in the code name.
Rogan get 10 percent off.
That's it.
That's the commercial boom Orisha fears
here.
Started the program,
Joe Rogan podcast,
revolutionizing commercials,
trying to get a smuggler for
Renzi.
Can Rip Missouri for showing.
First I was like,
I'll find.
Oh Wow.
And it was one all my favorites if you
guys want to take part in this.
But then somebody was like,
why don't you just pick them?
They're all over really.
And I realized like I trust my drug
dealer over what we find in nature.
I had a guy came up to me after a show.
It's one of the creepiest dudes ever.
It's just sweaty and weird and shit.
And he gave me a bag of mushrooms.
He man,
I picked these myself.
Like,
fuck,
I would fucking take your mushrooms
crazy face,
but you pick yourself up.
But who you trust the regular drug.
It's a weird looking dude and well,
you know,
you trust,
you trust people who know people who are
growing them.
You,
you got to get into the Matrix of the
where to get the mushrooms.
That's a problem.
The other ones are super poisoned.
I don't know.
You know,
I don't know how much difference
silicide mushrooms look than any other
mushrooms.
You know,
by the time I get them,
they're all dried out and we'll just
take care of them.
I've never seen one.
I don't think out in the wild.
I've never seen that red top.
Oh,
I've seen that man that was on my
property in Colorado.
So did you take that?
No,
I didn't.
I just took pictures
of it.
That's.
That was a red top of the dot with the,
with the spots with the whites.
Mario brother.
Ones the emoney to Ms Dot Darian.
Yeah.
That's the one that.
Isn't that the Marco Alegra?
Well,
no.
See that's why that's a very funky
mushroom.
It's a really different mushroom.
It's not.
It doesn't have silicide been in it.
It works in a completely different way
with your body.
It's a psychedelic,
but it's completely different and it's
seasonable.
It's variable genetically.
It's variable from different climates.
What we're getting in America,
I don't believe is the same am miscarry
a mushroom.
There's a been a lot of debate on this
amongst all those psychedelic kind of
sewers.
Those people was terrence Mckenna type
fellows.
And um,
that's one of the reasons why a lot of
people have taken it and it doesn't do
anything.
I took it once and it didn't do shit.
I took it with Doug Stanhope.
Maybe not.
I don't know,
man.
Yon made it.
So,
you know,
John's a fucking.
He's a,
he's a real head.
He's,
yeah,
he would.
And he did the,
he did the right thing.
He did it all right.
But it just wasn't getting us.
But then was it when you had,
did you eat anytime near that time that
you took it?
That exactly.
No,
no,
no.
We did it the right way.
We did it the right way,
but then,
uh,
we,
we mixed it with psilocybin mushrooms
dug through and some syllabi assignment.
Then we went to the fucking center of
the universe.
It's like mixing them together was a,
was a wow.
It was a total mind fuck.
And you know,
that was a,
one of the things that they believe is a
Soma Soma is,
was some sort of a mixture and it's
talked about with great reverence and
you know,
the,
the Hindu texts and Soma is greater than
Brahma,
greater than the bill so much.
No,
no,
that's just.
They just stole the word.
Soma is like the greatest psychedelic
ever apparently.
So what does that.
They don't know.
That's the craziest thing about it.
It's written with so much love,
but somehow somewhere they lost the
formula and nobody knows what it is.
So it's all debated.
Like Gordon Wasson thought it was
dominated with scary,
uh,
Mckenna.
I thought it was siliciden.
They think it might be a common atory
drug with psilocybin mixed in with some
other stuff and some people think it
might be psilocybin and Amany to
miscarry or they don't want to
miscarriage.
How does that hit you or what does that
do for you?
Well,
it depends on where you get it.
See,
everybody's getting,
like I said,
if I don't,
I can't speak from personal experience
because what I got didn't really work.
I don't think it's hard to tell because
it was like a few hours and it really
hadn't changed.
But without Psilocybin,
I don't know.
It's supposed to.
Yeah,
it's supposed to be able to,
but I don't know what form.
I don't know what part of the world you
got to get it.
It's variable.
That's the,
that's the issue with it.
It's not always psychedelic,
but what it is is Santa Claus,
the fucking,
the image of Santa Claus being this red
and white guy,
you know,
the image of the trees underneath the,
um,
the pine,
the,
excuse me,
the presence underneath the pine cones
are the pine trees.
They,
it has a microrisal relationship with
birch trees.
I mean,
it literally grows under these
fucking Christmas trees.
That's where it grows.
But wrapped in shiny colors.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
It's shiny as fuck Eddie Griffin
conspiracy theory.
It does,
but it really,
that's really what it is.
I mean,
the whole Christmas presents under the
tree thing is directly related to this
Amanita to miscarry mushroom.
It is red and white and the way they
drive these mushrooms out,
by the way,
as they hang them over the fireplace.
That's why people have red and white
stockings hanging over their fireplace.
Why the fuck else out to dry them out.
Nice.
Yeah.
That's what it is,
so that it's become this stocking.
Now.
What would it used to be his red and
white mushrooms hanging underneath your
fireplace?
Where's the proof of that?
So a lot of poop.
A lot of proof.
There's not only that,
all the old,
the old,
if you go back to all the old Christmas
cards,
they all have mushrooms in them.
Mushrooms,
symbology,
big emanate a mushroom in.
They have Christmas.
All the old Christmas cards at
Christmas.
They know more than the elves are.
What you see when you take mushrooms,
if you take enough and then on top of
it,
the elves are always playing with
mushrooms.
They always have this Aminay to miscarry
a mushroom and Santa Claus.
It's all.
Yeah.
If you go back and look like,
wait,
hold on.
I thought cola made up Santa Claus.
No,
no,
no.
When it comes to color,
no,
that was,
it was claimed.
But then proof became proof that there
was an artist from a,
at least I believe,
uh,
a decade or two before that who was
attributed to making Santa Claus Red and
white.
They thought that Santa Claus was one
color and then it was made red and white
because of,
um,
because of Coca Cola cocreated the
black.
It just created the black one.
I'm going to find some pictures for you.
And it was like groove it,
some Coca Cola Santa.
And so it was always had mushrooms stuff
in it.
And then Christmas time that have grown
in that time.
Um,
see I,
I look at this one over here.
Come on over here.
Look at this.
All these Christmas things.
Look at that.
And every single person that drew every
single one of those lived in California.
I do.
Dude,
you were retarded.
This is the oldest.
Fuck.
These are from the 17 hundreds.
Dude.
Okay.
Look,
this is old as fuck.
See this Chris Christmas look emanated.
Ms Dot mushroom.
That's a really old picture dude.
Okay.
There's,
there's a bunch of them.
Look at them.
This is like all this from a long time
ago.
That was the norm a long time ago in
Europe especially,
there was the norm given that website as
well.
Just just this is what I want you to
Google.
Just Google Santa and Anita miscarry a,
m u s immature,
but you look at the identity.
If you go to like say I don't know what
Christmas was born.
It seems like it was born in Germany or
something,
but if you go to Germany to Germany and
look at and try to find artwork of the
same Christmas stuff like in Germany
from that time period and I bet none of
them had mushrooms on.
They all had like,
you know,
you're just,
you're just guessing this off the top.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just saying,
you know,
I'm just saying that,
but that's what I would think you would
think wrong because I'm showing you
pictures of Christmas cards from
hundreds and have all these initiatives
that we're looking at.
Wacky Christmas card.
No,
no,
it's fine.
There's a lot of issues.
Look at this one right in the search.
We'll get this one right here with this.
Uh,
there's an old picture of Santa's and
he's got all these fucking laminated
miscarry and mushrooms at his feet.
Oh fuck man.
Let me find out old as fuck.
Officially.
Oldest.
Fuck.
I'll find out the agents of the
pictures.
But these,
these are,
you know,
these are like ancient fucking Christmas
card.
I see Santa Claus.
Why would you not see it?
I don't know.
It just like,
why is this not talked about all the
time?
Then,
you know,
like why?
Why is this not on regular TV news?
I feel like the Tower,
seven of holidays,
posture muscles are just in it for like,
there's so many correlations.
Listen,
listen to the connection.
So the,
the way they drive these fucking things
out is twofold.
One,
they hang them on the trees,
they put them in the branches.
So they drive by the sun,
or b,
they hang them under the fireplace.
What do they do?
You see fucking stockings.
Hang on the train,
you know,
it's probably literally grow under the
same tree that we use as a Christmas
tree and they are shiny packages and if
you get them from the right place,
apparently they make you trip the fuck
out and then their response,
that's the mushroom that they believe is
responsible for the,
you know the,
the writings in the Bible.
It's the sacred mushroom in the cross.
The laminated must carry mushroom is on
the cover of the sacred mushroom and the
cross.
It just makes sense to me that if
scholars believe that there's a
connection between this mushroom and
religious texts,
then of course there was a connection
between this mushroom and Santa Claus
and if you add up all the things that
line up as far as like hanging over the
fireplace and putting it on trees,
it totally could be possible.
So is if you go to the encyclopedia
Britannica headquarters in wherever that
would be,
like Wisconsin and you go through them
and go,
all right,
what is this Christmas to you?
What do you guys have about the mushroom
thing that they're like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Get it out of here,
hippie.
You know,
don't,
wouldn't you think that they're not that
willing to it to incorporate any sort of
illegal drug ideology into their,
their,
their work?
They probably just would ignore it even
if there's a lot of evidence.
So you think sometimes that people that
do a lot of mushrooms try to make
connections with everything and
definitely they do.
That's what my judge.
If I had to judge,
like if this was a game,
she said that's what my judgment would
be like.
Yeah.
That's just some hippie that made this
awesome connection.
It's a great story and that's what.
No,
that's what I'm thinking.
Okay.
Well that's a dumb way to think why.
Because scholars,
I'm not sold on anything.
I'm not sold that thing,
but I'm definitely not sold on you just
talking off your ass.
No,
I'm just putting a counterpoint.
The counterpoint to a fucking guy who
was a scholar.
John,
Marco Allegro studied the Tennessee
scholars that say the exact,
not the only ones that do are religious
ones.
I know,
but.
But who says that?
Religious.
He was an encyclopedia Britannica.
We're not talking about soccer,
but I'm just saying that going about the
Dead Sea scrolls wouldn't even been
encyclopedic.
Couldn't it be a part of the part of the
Christmas originally Pagan holiday and
there's going to be part of that Pagan
holiday.
Worse.
That ritual should definitely go over
that.
They use those guys.
It's just the.
The.
The real question is what's the elves?
What's with the fucking mushrooms and
all these Christmas pictures.
What's with the correlations?
Why do these mushrooms exist?
You know,
in why do they coincide with this
holiday?
What is the big deal?
But the big deal is these people were
tripping their fucking balls off.
Man.
That's what it is.
And it became somehow or another,
it gets turned into a,
a guy coming down the chimney and given
you presence.
What it was is this was.
This is some shit they found under the
tree.
That's much more likely to me if you've
got to fucking plant that makes you trip
balls and an ancient people find out
about it.
They worshiped that shit.
You know?
It becomes like a huge part of their
life.
Could you imagine if your world was the
regular world of people that live before
books?
You know,
I mean you're barely civilized.
Barely got it together.
People just getting by everyday big gets
sick.
Nobody know what the fuck was going on.
There was no doctors.
We just died,
man.
You just gave you some leaves to chew on
and usually just fucking died.
What if they found something like this?
If they found that there was some
mushrooms and you would eat them and all
of a sudden you'd be lying in a field
and fucking spiraling through the
universe and the most wild ride of,
of,
of joy and ecstasy of your life,
and then he would.
You would want to fucking praise that
shit.
You would want them to make that.
Yeah.
You would want to create a holiday.
You'd want to make it a part of your,
your,
your everyday life.
You would be worshiping it,
you know,
that's,
that's the feeling behind a lot of
people with why there was all this
cattle worship in the ancient world,
you know,
because no one can understand that.
Like why?
Why would you have these?
Like really aggressive primates.
They did worship cats.
Yeah.
But they didn't worship him like people
were like,
the Hindus worship the cows.
Cows are cows.
They just leave them alone.
No Man eat it.
Don't eat them.
They consider them sacred.
They consider them a site.
I don't,
I don't know.
Something,
something cool.
They consider them something cool.
But I think that has to do with the
media says about it.
And my mushrooms growing in the cow shit
is what we competed has about it.
About what Christmas is the relation for
mushrooms to um,
Santa Claus.
Okay.
Um,
flyer,
Garrick's peer.
I don't know what flight algorithms are.
Garrick's.
That's the,
the actual plant.
So,
okay.
Up here on Christmas cards and New
Year's cards from around the world as a
symbol of good luck.
The ethno botanists.
Jonathan suggested the idea of Santa
Claus and tradition of hang stockings
over the fireplace.
They essentially,
upon this mushroom itself,
there's a lot of people that have had
proposed in the red and white color
scheme.
You know,
it's a Santa Claus related to the
mushroom.
He also draws on parallels with flying
reindeer.
Randy had been reported to consume the
mushroom and prance around in an
intoxicated manner afterwards.
No wild.
That's what what's up,
but flying reindeer,
reindeer,
love emoney to miscarry mushrooms so
much,
and when people have these mushrooms and
they trip out the people,
yeah,
they do well when people will.
The other thing about Avalina Mascara,
mushrooms is about recycling the urine.
The way to really trip your balls off is
apparently a lot of whatever it is that
psychoactive inside the mushroom is.
It passes through your body and into
your urine and if you drink your urine
kicks the whole experience to the next
level.
What do you mean while you're on it?
While you're tripping balls,
you're going to go deep,
deep,
deep.
The guy who told me who did it said it
was.
It was crazy.
It was like he was tripping and
everybody's like,
okay,
if you have to pay,
you got to drink your pee,
and he's like,
fuck man,
I want to drink my pm already tripping
balls.
This is good,
this is good.
And he drank his penis like through yet
psilocybin mushrooms.
That's the case and we need to miscarry
mushrooms.
I'd be like,
dude,
don't trust her.
This is just the mushrooms talking to
not know that.
So the Shaman talking.
That's like the the ancient tradition of
doing it.
If that's how you take it to the next
level while you're in the middle of your
mushroom experience,
he'd drink your urine and whatever it is
still listen,
the Psilocybin,
whatever it is,
it's passed through.
I don't know that the technical
components of it,
but apparently talking to several people
who've done this but this guy says,
is that if Santa Claus had one eye or if
magic urine to be part of his legend,
it'd be way easier to believe,
but it's.
That's why it's not.
That's why there's dispute because like
it's not super clear.
Well,
yeah.
Who the fuck knows?
I think it's possible that there was an
article about in the magazine Sunday,
Sunday Times in 1980 and the new
scientist and intensity to six.
So those are,
those are legitimate.
Yeah,
well it's not,
you know,
this is not my wacky idea.
This is an idea that's been kicked
around for decades.
People believe it,
that are,
uh,
you know,
like they're serious scholars that
believe in this silly idea.
But uh,
the um,
the whole idea of it being illegal is
what's the most fascinating thing to me,
you know,
these mushrooms real legal,
that this is a,
this is somehow or another,
some person has decided to pass some
sort of a law saying that you can't
experience this.
That's bad for it.
I was walking out of a pot store once,
early on at Zen.
I was like,
I still felt like it's like cool that
I'm having drugs and I still the cop on
the corner,
I was like,
doesn't matter.
I'm holding my truck.
And I realized my other hand,
I had a bag of mushrooms.
I was like,
oh,
this I got to try not to be so weird.
You'd fucking Dork walking under this
tree with mushrooms in your hand.
Wow.
You just live in that crazy comedy
lifeson.
Yeah,
you get it.
They don't care in la,
but I hope it stays this way.
You know,
it's the real issue is the federal
issue.
You know,
if we could find one cool spot and if
they,
you know,
supported states rights,
we could find a cool spot where we can
make pretty much everything legal.
We all got together
and said,
hey,
we're gonna have one.
Clarity state is a state where murders,
murder,
crime theft,
all that stuff.
Yeah.
That's all illegal.
Arson.
Silly.
Yeah.
The rest of it shut up and the rest of
it just shut the fuck up.
There's too many God damn laws.
This is.
This is how it's going to go down.
This is where the money's going to go
here.
This is going to be legal and this will
be regulated.
This,
you know,
you have to buy in the store will then
you'll know it's pure and it's tested by
the government.
That's where the government can help out
test mushrooms.
That's what you want.
You want to help out,
you want to really be of service to the
people.
This is what we do.
We get rid of some of the government job
at John Hopkins Study,
right?
And we bring the John Hopkins Study said
that people taking mushrooms,
even just one experience significantly
affected them for decades,
significantly affected their
personality,
change it for the better.
I've,
I know psychedelic experience has
changed me.
I know every time I take them when I
have like thoughts of what I need to do
right or what I'm doing wrong or what's,
what's fucking with me or that's.
Those are just jolts of reality that you
don't get unless you take a psychedelic.
You can,
you can get,
like when you meditate outside you
really easily.
You could get pretty deep when you're
meditating.
I'm not above,
uh,
the idea that some people can get to
psychedelic states naturally because
it's been written about by so many
people.
I think it's a discipline issue.
I think it's just like,
like you could tell someone,
hey,
uh,
you know,
I could teach you martial arts and uh,
you could go and kick somebody's ass and
then you're like really short and then I
give you like one lesson and throw you
in there and the guy like Marcella
Garcia and you just get manhandled.
Like,
I could never fucking do this because I
don't think it's a one.
I don't think a lot of people that
would.
What you think is possible due to
meditation is based on your level of
meditation.
How,
how deep have you taken it?
You know what I mean?
How relaxed do you get?
How centered do you get when you
meditate?
Because some people get super distracted
and it never gets more than A.
Yeah.
It never gets more than a surface.
Sort of like a relaxation real deep.
With mushrooms I take a little bit like
see,
like the universal truths sort of hold
onto it barely for like a second or two
or like a day.
But then it's like the more I go,
the more I can bring back and remember
like,
Oh yeah,
this thing I gotta write all about.
You know,
it's always humbling.
Humbling.
Yeah.
It's like you don't matter.
You don't matter what you do.
Once you do.
I mean you do your,
you have intent and you have,
you know,
will and you can spread positive energy.
You,
you do matter,
you matter.
But I mean,
God damn this is a lot of us know and
we're all a part of one thing.
If we all matter,
then you matter as well.
It's not that you don't matter,
but God damn it's big.
It's fucking giant.
It's all encompassing.
It's not just your house,
it's not just your car,
it's not just your street or your
neighborhood.
It's the whole fucking universe.
And it's all together in one giant
fucking soup.
We just can't feel it.
We just can't feel.
We feel like there's.
Well
there's distance between us and Mars
does no distance.
Everything between this and that.
There is something there.
Whether it's dark matter or shit you
can't see or stuff we haven't
discovered.
There is nowhere where there's not
something,
there's no,
even in a vacuum,
there's something if there's something
everywhere and you know,
whether it's Subatomic,
whether it's we are connected to
everything everywhere and that is
impossible to recognize without some
sort of a full blown psychedelic
experience.
It takes something like that to feel it
because otherwise it's just a bunch of
words because I thought all those words
before,
you know,
I thought all of those words like,
yeah,
you know,
it's kind of corrupting for all kind of
connected and you know,
and I think yeah,
the universe is huge and you know,
I had all those thoughts before
psychedelics and I had them with,
you know,
a certain amount of clarity.
But there's a big difference between.
I feel like it sucks you out and just
makes you seem like you're just one of,
even in your state of so many people
that you're just like a blip and then
you see time before you and after you
when you're like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
It's insane.
It's insane to think that you know,
that we have this short amount of time
here and it seems like as the time goes
on and you just start figuring out what
the fuck is going on,
you know,
like as you get to that's.
That's like the thing about people
today.
We live long enough to see the hustle.
We live long enough to see the bullshit.
You know,
if we were Romans,
man,
we would all be long dead.
All of us were not.
You're in your thirties.
I'm in my forties.
We're dead.
People were dead.
There's no way we'd be alive,
totally crippled.
We'd have lion bites on our dicks and
shit.
One of us will be missing an arm or
something.
You know,
you,
you get fucked up back then,
man.
But today we can live and we live safely
and we have enough nutrition and you're
eating vitamins and everything and you
live long enough to see like God damn
hustle.
Ten years ago they said one of two
people in England would live to see 100.
God Damn.
Why don't you learn to live in a castle
though?
Back in the day like where you had the
little courtyards,
little houses in between like inside the
vessel,
like a,
like a really big one.
I think that would be crazy.
It gives you,
you have this one giant house and
everybody around you has little houses.
That's the dumbest way to live mean
when.
That'd be cool.
Just to like experience it for like
three days or something.
Like I'd like to have all those people
in those little houses want to kill you
is gold.
Yeah.
I wonder if it was like that.
Imagine that if everybody else is
starving and there's this giant house
with people that are eaten.
Gold sandwiches.
Sound like you're describing Bashar
Assad.
Bashar Assad was a leader theory.
Oh really?
Like everyone's starting to revolt,
but it's like I stuck out the guns.
Oh Wow.
It's,
it's how crazy is that whole Arab area,
the whole Arab spring thing and what it
does is nuts.
Man.
That guy,
my death pool.
Did you really?
Yeah.
It's a strange,
strange time for the whole part of the.
They're all the internet making
everybody like,
wait,
what?
Did what over there?
Really?
Yeah,
well they,
they see that you let them have the
Internet really,
and he finally like lax on the Internet
and then they was like,
man,
it was his downfall.
Yeah.
That in the CIA bitch,
you know,
the CIA had a little piece of outside
influence,
like you shouldn't be listening.
That's the spies that are starting all
this,
but maybe.
Yeah,
that's the best way to overthrow them.
Get their own people to do it for us.
Yeah,
sure.
Arm,
arm armed and all we're trying to get
them to do is just live free.
Yeah.
But that shit don't work that way.
Make the new boss same as the old boss.
That's what's going on in Iraq right
now.
Iraq apparently is just a fucking mess
right now.
Like,
yeah,
there's like a civil war about to break
out.
So they always say as soon as it
happened,
as soon as we left,
I was just kind of happen,
right?
Course,
man,
we,
you know,
there's a vacuum and when there's a
vacuum someone's going to seek to fill
it.
And there's a lot of people that are
still alive that were alive back during
the Saddam era,
you know,
and those,
those people are going to try to get
control of that bitch and then there's
new people moving in and then there's
also the idea that,
you know,
the connection between Iraq and
Afghanistan and all of our resources and
went where the fuck is this country
going and why do we have 100 different
bases all over the country or the world.
It's like,
what are we wasting our time and our
resources on?
Is this really necessary anymore?
Or is this just a bunch of people who
have contracts and we keep giving them
contracts because it's just what we've
always done.
And that's how they got involved.
That's how they keep politicians in
office.
And then we're stuck because that's.
It seems like what it is,
we're fucked.
What really said,
what I occupied Wall Street finally sat
there.
Like the problem is if you get sponsored
by a big corporation,
you know,
they give you a bunch of money for your
campaign,
they can effectively fire you by
withholding that money that you need to
get elected.
Again.
You know,
it's like good luck doing this without,
you know,
$500,000,000
in your,
in your ad budget this year,
or how much of that is probably a lot
more.
I don't know.
You need to get those bitches.
Mushrooms.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
That's what we need to do Christmas.
That's a good answer to a lot of things.
Getting those bitches on mushrooms,
I tell it to eliminate people really is
true either.
I'm like,
when's the last time we did some
mushrooms?
Maybe some.
It sounds like I did mushrooms.
I found something crazy.
Like I had a huge bag of really good
mushrooms and I took half of them and
trip my ass off hardest.
I bet you know,
super hard trip
visual.
Hang on,
hold on,
hold on.
This real quick.
I don't want you to get back to throw
it.
This is where I realize everybody's
like,
oh,
the mushrooms.
I got a super good and everybody says
that,
but they really mean is mushrooms are
super good.
Yeah.
Well,
well,
well then.
And then I,
you ever got bad ones?
No,
I have the first time.
The first time I took it had the
greatest time.
Second time I ate like two hours before
and was just like sitting on a couch
watching time and
going,
wow,
this is all right.
But then I took more the second time it
was the same mushrooms and uh,
the first time I tripped my ass off
because I didn't eat anything else the
whole day.
Oh,
well it also could be,
you know,
I've heard of people getting mushrooms.
Actually it hurt.
You have mushrooms,
you'd set out some mold on it.
You like food poisoning it,
you know,
I think that's what's going to happen.
I think sometimes you get sick from
mushrooms and that's usually because he
had never gotten sick from barb to the
first time I got a billy goat stomach.
I couldn't eat some shit.
I'd never barked.
But my friend who gave it to me the
first time used to make them,
her buddy was said,
you will get,
you'll feel nauseous,
like you're gonna throw up.
He's like,
you won't throw up.
Just sit down and look up in the air for
a while.
The feeling will pass fear factor
completely changed my whole ability to
withstand smells and,
and people vomit or you can handle
anything.
Now I'm immune.
I'm completely immune to getting sick,
watching someone vomit,
you know,
because I used to get.
I used to physically gag if I smelled
puke,
like I was a kid.
You remember?
You know what I was getting knocked baby
was no problem for me,
man.
I just sat right through.
The wind would shift and you catch a
whiff of it?
Yeah,
it was.
It was horrendous baby bird.
If you don't know it was the greatest
gag in the history of race.
And Ari and I were there,
uh,
we'll burn bill burger and a chimney.
Norton.
And what it was was there was this crazy
kid that they had working for opiod,
Anthony,
and his name is Pat Duffy.
You got to back up this.
Well,
this is.
I'm going to,
I'm going to explain it through this
way.
I'm just going to split in this kid and
they get this kid to do anything.
This kid brushed his teeth with dog
shit.
He was,
he was a maniac.
He's a fucking maniac.
I saw him drink other people's puke.
I saw him drink a glass full of other
dudes.
PUKES dudes threw up.
There was some sort of eating contest.
There was a uh,
economic drinking contest.
Yeah.
But that's.
This was a different one.
I'm talking about a different one,
but I've seen him,
I've seen him do some ridiculous shit
before this.
So we had a bunch of their guys there
for the egg drinking contest and pat
from hockey is the ace in the hole.
He winds that bitch every year.
He's got diabetes.
He's done with.
Yeah.
So he's not supposed to be drinking
eggnog at the first place and he's
drinking like fucking gallons of it.
He's a big boy.
It's a double shot every 60 seconds.
And he's up to like 70,
70 glasses like chucking.
Oh man,
like seven,
eight in some people.
Some people.
By the way,
this is non alcoholic,
this just eggnog.
Um,
something because if he drank like 70
shots,
he'd be a dead man.
You'd be a dead.
But um,
so what was your question?
When did people start,
start,
start Fokker?
Because it was the.
Yeah,
he got up to like 70 shots.
I believe it was something insane.
It was ridiculous.
And he said he was going to puke and we
were trying to figure out what to do
with the puke and just as a joke,
I did not think anybody would say that.
I said,
why don't you have this kid leaned his
head into the,
into the,
the garbage pail and have pat throw up
in his mouth.
I just came up with the dumbest shit
ever because like,
I didn't think anybody would say yes.
And we were on edibles at the time,
probably put up 99 percent.
I always am if I do.
And Anthony,
um,
so we were high as a kite and I never
thought anyway,
it was just going crazy extremes.
Yeah,
it was ridiculous.
The dude late,
he laid on his back with my,
with the garbage pail and put his,
put his body into it,
like he was going to open up a wash for
a haircut just all the way back.
Yeah.
It was one of those big tubs.
Nice.
Good size,
garbage pail.
And he leans back and opens his mouth.
And this guy had from.
Oh,
knocking.
It's available online.
Right.
You can watch it.
Had to have the videos online.
One got taken down because somebody
complained that it was disgusting.
But there's another one on there.
Can you find it somewhere?
Just find a play it.
Why can't we play it?
Because you don't have that technology
at this here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Um,
either way at this one.
That technology here.
Yeah.
Um,
but.
So there's this dude.
I mean you could just picture a baby
bird.
This picture,
I believe there's video to the,
the amount,
the volumes that came out of his mouth
enveloping the other guy who was insane.
It was the craziest thing I'd ever seen
anybody ever do.
I mean,
he's hurling her holding onto this guy's
face and it's like a cartoon throw up.
It doesn't totally doesn't look real.
You remember a bucket of water,
the windows.
So much.
Giant man just unloading and you know
what?
I talked to Opie and Anthony.
They said they would never be able to do
that again.
What?
They said,
you can't do that again.
Friesan trench reasons they've tightened
dangerous.
Fuck dangerous.
No one died.
Somebody died in Sacramento,
I believe it was in Sacramento from
water.
They were drinking water.
Water.
See how long ago she.
She,
she died from an overdose of water
break.com.
Is it on breakdown?
Oh,
beautiful.
Go check that out folks.
Trust me.
It's worth just sheer ridiculousness.
It's just one of the most ridiculous
things I've ever seen a person do ever.
We were there already.
That was so great.
It was.
No,
you weren't there Brian.
No.
You put the videos that you were sending
in a video.
He,
um,
wish you were there.
The barfing started like seven minutes.
People will like throw up and they were
out and then more he'll start buying the
one guy barfed into some,
you know,
fruit loops or eating it with,
oh my God,
that's fucking that same kid pat off and
it just ramped up.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
Because of that.
Oh,
that's right.
I forgot that part and it was just like,
oh,
thing and building so much bar from the
air.
If you want to have a.
If you want to be a shock jock,
that kid is the greatest intern you
could ever hope to hire.
I mean,
that kid's a goddamn kamikaze if he's
still alive.
He's alive.
He's alive,
he's alive.
He messaged me on twitter a while back.
He kept throwing stuff and enroll in
space.
Yeah,
and he would almost bar.
They kept showing it to them.
The fruit loops.
Disgusting is the picture.
It's the baby bird.
Oh,
and a do a google image search.
It's the first one that pops up.
Amazing photo it is to load on to show.
This is so silly.
It's so great.
I knew what we were starting to do that
anymore.
There's massive law,
massive lawsuits,
massive,
uh,
you know,
just really wouldn't be what it is.
Basically,
you know,
they've,
they've clamped down and they made sure
that there's less probability for
getting sued and when there's less
probability of getting sued,
there's also less a probability.
Something fucking crazy happening.
Supreme Court entertainment just took on
the case.
You would love those of.
I'm getting rid of the FCC standards on
network television.
Really?
Yeah.
They said pretty much since nine,
nine percent of people have cable.
It's ridiculous.
Anyway,
channel seven's okay.
Which it's not like why?
Um,
uh,
yeah.
And they're hearing it now with that.
No,
not anymore.
But I still find people,
unfortunately people are going to fight
it though.
There's a lot of like pro family,
Pro Christian radio,
you know,
like there'll be a program to be able to
show you if there's nudity at.
I've looked at that photo,
my God,
look at that photo.
Jesus Christ.
You can put that picture up.
You can put that picture up in the.
Oh,
is this the only way to do it here?
No.
Alright.
You email it to me.
I could do it.
Okay.
Is that the most ridiculous shit?
It's so it looks like he's a spider,
like breaking it down with his end
science.
Breaking down that other guy.
It looks like a cartoon.
Anyway,
we'll talk about something before I get
sick.
God Damn.
Yeah.
You can't do that anymore.
It's no fun.
I mean if you want to have a business,
I mean you got to think and when you get
involved in something like serious look,
gigantic fucking huge company that's
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
for everything.
Yeah.
Because you assholes want to drink egg?
Hey idiot face.
That's the problem man.
You know,
Anthony Cumi is uh,
his show is now on itunes and he's got a
video on it.
He has video on itunes.
Yeah.
I tried doing that.
I think.
I don't know,
but.
Well he's paying for video.
A video host.
Wow.
But I tried to do it twice now and the
video wouldn't play.
His bandwidth must be fucked or
something like that goes.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
I just did it.
I bet he probably doesn't realize how
much money is going to have bandwidth.
What people don't realize,
you have to have a host,
like if if you put something on itunes
and it is free,
you know,
I mean you,
you can put your shit on itunes but
someone has to be downloaded it from
somewhere and you have to have a host
where they doubt like itunes is not like
storing
your stuff.
They're not providing bandwidth.
They're basically providing a link to a
website,
a server that you pay for.
And what's funny is that there's a lot
of web hosts,
like unfortunately I used dreamhost,
which at all my life has has been great,
but I had to switch to a cloud computing
thing where like a,
but it was unlimited bandwidth.
Unlimited storage.
No,
I'm on that.
And then.
But what they don't tell you is no,
wait,
it doesn't count like unlimited memory
of the computer or something like that.
If there's too many people and yeah.
So then you have to raise your bandwidth
and it's some bullshit.
The whole thing is a fucking unlimited
bandwidth and they tell you they trick
you,
they because then they're like,
oh yeah,
well it's unlimited debt,
but you know,
it's your memory,
you know,
in your computers,
you got to have more,
you know,
they trick in that.
So they make you buy more hard drives or
computer program.
Like what do you mean by memory?
Do you mean like data storage space or
is it like Ram Ram?
Pretty much so you buy more ram and
then.
So I like now you're done by Ram,
but what's bullshit is like dreamhost.
I don't,
I'm sorry,
I'm going to start bashing you now,
but a dreamhost like we'll have your
dream house.
You can search,
you can search like how you can have
graphs of how much you use,
how much ram you use every hour.
Right?
And so you like,
I think I'm paying for,
I forget how many,
let's just say a thousand ram.
It will not be using the 400 most of the
time and then out of nowhere my shit
will crash and they're like,
oh,
you need to up your even more random.
I think they'll do.
You're,
you're running a lot of traffic.
No,
no,
but what they're saying is that my ram
has doubled in one second and crashes
the computer,
but it doesn't show it on the graph and
they're like,
oh,
let's just their spikes.
And I'm like,
yeah,
spice a doubling in one second and you
don't have it on your graph.
Oh.
So then they make you go.
Yeah.
They can't prove it to you for no
reason.
It's so fucking bullshit.
You feel like you got ganged.
I'm getting ganged every day with
fucking dream host.
And what's funny is I've had a website
with them for a long ass time and before
I was on.
Before I was on cloud computing before,
but when I was just spinning like $18 a
month,
I still had a website that got hit a
lot.
You're doing all the videos at Carl's
been sia videos and all those other
videos we used to do all the time.
My shit got hit a lot and it never went
down.
It never was a problem.
But they get you on these cloud
computing's now it's just fucking dream
host.
So I'm saying were,
wow,
this is a very angry Brian dreamhost is
all fired up,
man.
Find stuff,
gets passionate about his poor little
site.
It's,
you know,
I feel like you'd be like a lot more
comfortable.
He just had a wikipedia page.
I'm getting beat by a.
So you really believe that if you get
this shorty award thing that somehow or
another a few adminis administers who
have contacted me through wikipedia and
just fucking trail and you want to tell
you a story about George and then once
once you get a shorty
award,
they're going to go,
who the fuck gives a shit about your
shorty award bids?
And then he got to be like,
God Damn Shorty Award.
They're making me work for it.
Those wikipedia bits making you better.
Oscar for patent and said,
I'm not going to that.
And just didn't show up because what the
fuck do I care?
Wow.
Well,
he was a bad motherfucker.
Did you ever see the hustler?
George C dot Scott was a scary character
in the hustling.
You owe me money.
A scary dude,
man.
This is after he.
He's saying he's screaming that Depaul
Newman after he fucked Paul Newman's
girlfriend and forced her to commit
suicide.
And then he said,
you owe me money.
I was like,
whoa.
It was a scary dude because that was a
great fucking movie man.
Imagine how good that moving must've
been in like why?
What was it like 64 or something like
that was a really old movie.
You know?
Imagine how good it was that fucking.
There's some movies managers hold up and
there's other ones you watch.
You just go,
what the fuck?
Like what happened?
What happened between,
you know,
I was going to come to it when I saw
stuff like that in movies.
I don't know why it made me like,
feel extra bet with some girl being
unfaithful really fucking over somebody
sexually.
I'd always made me feel like,
Oh god,
that bothers you the most way,
worse than a to homeless people.
Did you when you were a young girl that
you were really in love with?
And she,
she left him for another dude.
He always thought that that was gonna
happen.
Maybe.
Maybe that's maybe because it didn't
happen seat to me,
my data to gang up pores in a row and I
caught a bunch of them,
Bang another dudes.
And so when that happens,
it's like,
it lowers expectations so it's fine,
you know?
I mean,
I,
I realized as I got older than it was
mostly my fault and I was attracted the
wrong person into my life.
You know,
you're tracking but you're tracking
somebody.
No,
no,
no.
Or just like the fuck.
And you're like,
damn it on love.
Part of it is that,
and part of it is subconsciously,
I think you're just trying to attract
the wrong person possible.
Subconsciously you don't think you're
worthy of anybody any good.
So you can just get these nightmares
that you know are never going to last
and then you get stuck.
I love how Dr you're always says that of
like you always say this type of person.
I'm like,
no.
I mean,
yeah,
they all hit me,
but what do you mean there's no
correlation?
Right.
My Dad had made.
People are fucking strange with
patterns.
Man.
That's strange with getting locked into
things.
You know,
like I,
I knew dudes and I never understood
this.
They could not stop going to the track.
They would go to the race track and to
them it was their crack man.
They,
there was guys that didn't even have any
money and they would go and hang out
with dudes who had money hoping that if
the guy wants something,
he would give them a gapper so they
could fucking put it on.
Yeah,
well that's the gamblers creed.
A gapper is he throwed 20 this guy's
way.
He sweats your match.
You throw 50 his way.
Like it's a big thing in the pool world,
like say if
you know,
if you are hanging with a bunch of guys
and everyone's broken,
one guy wins a bunch of money,
he'll give his friend some money if
you're hanging out with them and they
sweat is match,
watch,
watch this match.
And it's sort of like when you give guys
gappers it gets,
you know,
it's the right intention.
It spreads a little money around that
way one day when you're broke because
all the pool hustlers,
all all professional pool players at one
point in time we're probably broke or
will be broke again.
It's a tough one.
You know when you're out there gambling
and you're trying to play in tournaments
and you can't get roles and you're
trying to make money and you're trying
to pay for hotel bills and it's a hard
life.
Was the life of the professional pool
player at of all the skill games of the
world might be one of the hardest lines.
They don't make that much money,
man.
It's hard.
It's a hard gig.
It's hard to put it together.
There's only a few guys at the very top
that really make money aren't.
It's how much easier your gigs the
easiest,
but you got to be funny if you're not
funny or Gigis to death.
We can't catch a break if you're not
supposed to be a comedian.
Our gig is the scariest thing in the
world for a lot of people.
A lot of guys weren't supposed to be.
Comedians are doing.
Isn't that weird?
It is weird.
You're like,
what?
We all.
Everyone agrees you're bad.
It's.
Yeah.
It's weird how some guys,
even though they're terrible,
somehow or another,
they wound up sticking around long
enough to get paid for it occasionally
and not a lot,
but every now and then they'll get a gig
here and a gig there and you'll have
plenty of money and you're like,
what the fuck is going on?
Like,
is it just,
uh,
making friends thing title?
And it's totally a lot of it because
there's a few people that we know who
they are and we to have to say any names
here,
but when they go on stage,
it's like they're,
they're doing their best impression of a
comedian.
Yeah.
You know,
I think everybody who starts comedy,
sure.
But these are like,
let me get the impression.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
those will you work with them on the
road somewhere and you're like,
what the fuck am I seeing?
But they tricked somebody into hiring
them somewhere.
I think there's enough comedians now
that they don't ever have to do that
anymore.
There's not necessarily one of us,
you know,
there's enough comedians,
you just kinda like getting Qa.
It needs to be a network where people
can find where the good ones are.
I sent a resurgence,
I said I think comedy back all this junk
is helping a lot of people get to know
people were easier.
Yeah.
Podcast help for sure.
They're like,
oh,
these comedians are like cool thing sort
of talking and stuff.
And yeah,
having having a podcast and having
people come to the shows because of the
podcast,
but I think even besides outside of the
like,
like Louis Ck,
you know,
his situation where selling is things
online.
I think that gives a big resurgence to
it too.
People hear the story about it.
I just remember the last comic standing
start at the comedy store.
Numbers went way up.
I had remembered.
Oh yeah,
comedy.
Comedy is fucking great man.
Such a great night.
Yeah.
As a fan,
you know,
before I was ever a comedian,
that was my favorite thing to do.
Yeah.
I would never pay a lot extra for it on
new years because I've seen too much or
anything like that.
Like it's just a good fun date.
Yeah.
Especially,
you know,
if people in town,
whatever.
Yeah,
we've gone on the road and I have a
couple of times and I'm in town when
someone I'd like is playing someone,
then I go see him and I can actually sit
and watch like a,
the store.
It's a bastion of so goddamn funny.
Really.
He's so fucking funny.
Yeah.
It's just so fun to watch.
I was like,
yeah,
somebody made a date out of this.
It's,
it's cool art form,
man.
I love watching just as much as I love
doing it.
Yeah,
we're lucky as shit,
man.
I've watched ice road truckers the other
day.
That's way harder.
It's way harder.
Imagine being an ice road trucker.
Imagine that.
I know the worst job,
the worst job.
What's the worst job?
Do you want to hookers?
Cost cost $2 and it's the breakdown was
set 60 for the girl,
but she splits up with a pim.
However,
I'm not sure.
Uh,
11 for the room and one for the cleanup
guy.
That's the worst job.
One dollar cleanup.
Just spots and probably over and over
again.
Just just a ton of people all over
everybody.
Everything's going on during the day.
There's still at full capacity in
business.
It's really crazy how close that is to
San Diego that everybody used to do that
as their trip.
But could you imagine man,
being a person who lives in Tijuana and
just knowing that San Diego is right
there and right there,
there's white people with $7,
million dollar houses on the beach and
they're drinking.
Margarita does and talking about their
pedicure lady grows border town.
You're in a house made out of cardboard.
It's just 20 minutes away.
Drive to their house in 20 minutes.
That's insane.
How weird is that?
Weird.
Is it?
That is a third world and the peak of
the first world.
San Diego is a pretty God damn nice.
Beautiful play.
Yeah.
There's one,
there's one island.
I forget what the island is.
It's off of San Diego.
It's like a little,
a very small and very exclusive island
where it's one of the richest pieces of
real estate in the country.
That's what Donald Rumsfeld.
No Catalina's off of this area.
It's like Santa Monica.
This one is off.
It's a small jump between this.
And I forget what it's called.
Super wealthy people like ridiculous,
stupid fucking mansions,
you know,
$20,000,000
properties.
Shit like that.
And that's like a drive to Mexico.
Man.
It's so bizarre and I guess I dunno,
I mean I guess the Mexicans,
if they want to get in the boat and just
sneak up and get that really quick,
just pull into their neighborhood with a
boat for real man.
You could be like hardcore Mexican,
you know,
gang bangers.
They have some castles.
They're hardcore Mexican drug dealers
and just getting a boat,
just get in a boat and figured out a way
to just do it by cover of night.
Going to rehab there.
Do they really do.
Like I said,
don't get off the sauce.
What's really were in,
in to
all the border towns.
Like how you said that too.
Don't get off the sauce.
So if you're in 19 forties movie,
bad guy,
who the fuck is that?
You listen to me say watching old movies
like watching a movie from another
country.
I've been watching the one where we
really mad it's not.
So that's
for like 20 years ago we were talking
about like Clark Gable type shit.
You're talking about Billy Madison.
I'm talking about watching some stuff
from wash some stuff from like the
forties and fifties.
I love it.
I'm addicted.
Different language.
I love looking at that.
Or what have you ever seen?
That's good.
I just watched.
Um,
Ooh,
that's a great site with the one with
Clark Gable.
A gone with the wind.
Oh yeah.
That's great.
We talked about that yet,
but it was weird.
It had like slavery aspects in that and
stuff like that.
Yeah.
Well that's what's going down back then.
There was something else I just watched
here.
Have you ever seen who's afraid of
Virginia Woolf?
No.
So I'm Elizabeth with the flux.
Her name,
the pitcher got married 100,000
times.
Liz Taylor,
Elizabeth Taylor,
Elizabeth Taylor when she was hot as
fuck.
Fine.
When she was young.
My God,
that woman was.
That's why we still talk about her.
She was hot.
I don't know if she's still alive,
you know,
I don't know,
but she's,
you know,
she's getting older.
She's married.
Couple of gay guys along the way.
It got,
it got weird for awhile.
Poor lady when she was young though,
man.
God Damn.
I mean,
it falls apart for everybody,
but I think for her it was just.
That's such a great thing.
Did you ever watch you the wall?
Everybody hits the wall.
You're like an $800,
billion years of development wall has
never lost.
Undefeated was $6 billion in.
Oh no one's ever beaten the wall.
Wall's coming and bitch.
It's coming for you too.
Did you ever see the color purple?
Yes.
I think obviously the what color color
granola.
I might not have seen that.
I was really stoned and watching oprah
and it was really weird.
Slavery,
sexual slavery Shit,
and it was weird.
That was a big part of slavery.
So we're a big part of slavery.
Was the master coming down and banging
the Danny Glover was legit,
man.
They used to have children,
but yeah,
but that's what it was.
I couldn't watch it.
It was just too,
too creepy.
Kalpa was right after slavery.
He thought.
What was the color purple?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure I didn't actually say
it.
It's one of those that I always intend
on seeing,
but I never get around to it,
but I think it was like super common for
the slave owners to have sex with their
slaves.
Oh yeah.
Benjamin Franklin,
right.
You have a ton of grandkids that will
wonder how many of the male slaves had
sex with the women because that must
have been going on too,
where women were ignored and slaves to
bang them.
God,
the punishment for that was just clearly
duff.
I'm wonder,
is it worth it?
I wonder.
I wonder if you're allowed to.
They must.
Must've been those stories of having ha,
she gets pregnant.
Who did it?
Yeah.
I mean,
listen man,
as long as there's dudes sling and Dick,
this chick's jumping on them.
As long as I've been black people,
they have been attracted to white women
and as long as had been white women,
they've been attracted to black now like
my weed and smoke my dick to the slave.
That's what she would say,
and that's what you would say to you,
your Arcelor grow my weed and suck my
dick smoked.
My Dad smoked my deck.
Brian sometimes write these down and go
over them and go,
is this worth it?
Interjecting in their grill,
my wheels out and you're like,
dammit,
that wasn't good.
So then when it comes from a good place,
we have to remember that we're talking
about if I was.
You guys were talking about slaves,
right?
Knocking your slaves.
Yeah,
I get ya.
And I just said I wouldn't be doing a
bit.
I just thought it was trying to talk to
him.
It's okay buddy.
We're just trying to keep the
conversation moving.
I'm not trying to be harsh.
I'm going to be in Minneapolis when you
do it at the end of.
I'm an acme brick.
Bronson's house of comedy.
Oh,
what is that new place?
Yeah,
he owns the place that I mentioned,
so I love Minneapolis,
but I can't say that fucking wintertime.
Son To mall of America.
I might never have to leave.
So you go.
You fly into the mall?
No,
I will have to go from the flight.
Somehow or other.
You're going to be outside.
You're going to have to be in that tube
plate.
The winter.
It's cold as fuck.
It's like it gets like Zeros.
That's why I'm going to.
Thursday.
It's going to start snowing.
Third,
Ohio.
Yeah.
Right now it's $50.
Supposedly.
There's just like the sleet and freezing
rain and snow storms.
Shit gone that day.
I planned I,
I hit freezing rain once in Ohio to the
three 60 on the highway.
Really?
Yup.
Me and Christopher Dwyer.
Threesixty.
Yup.
Flipped all the way around.
Mr.
Guardrail missed everything.
We just kept driving.
My Dad was driving over the bridge,
you know,
how's your bridges and bridges is a
place where for.
Yeah.
Because actually the wind coming the
fruit.
So how about that?
Three 60 on a bridge.
What'd you hit?
Nothing.
Wow.
Yeah.
Spun around.
That must be God,
right?
Yep.
Yeah.
That must be.
Why isn't it?
God Ari fucking.
Maybe it's the secret.
Maybe you did that.
Go.
Maybe engineered it.
So my dad used to have this giant
suburban,
the old style suburbans oh those are
great.
Second and third motor in it.
He just kept it going.
But he would see people start to skid
like in the,
in the snow and like come and like,
uh,
you know,
10 miles an hour just like that.
He just like,
here we go,
let's just get some cash.
He's just trying to be like,
let's just do this off the books.
Oh,
that's what you do.
Serious.
Never fixed shit going to be about looks
like $800 of damage.
Right?
Let's go,
let's do this.
And they would give him 800 bucks.
How many people hit him?
It happened like every other song do we
do just go out when it's stolen and try
to make sure this is one stop earning a
university.
And when they cut their university in
Arcola,
it wouldn't be like,
it was just downhill and it was like
people will start to go there,
then just quit and stop.
It could cover snow and if you're the
bottom of the hill,
they're
coming right at you.
Nothing you can do.
I lived on a street that a completely
froze and became a hockey rink.
And me and my girlfriends or my brother
and my sister's boyfriend sat on the
roof and watch.
We drank beers and watch cars crash.
Slide down the hill.
It's my favorite,
but watching that we called the cops.
We called the cops and the cops fucking
do the same thing.
They did the same thing.
We told them we saw the first car slide
by the house and we're like,
what the fuck?
I go,
dude,
I think the street is ice now.
And so we,
uh,
we opened up the door and looked and it
looked like ice.
I'm like,
it looks wet for sure.
And I got up to him like,
fuck,
it's just a whole,
the whole street.
And we were on a hill.
So the whole street is just a sheet of
ice.
And one after another car just came down
and boom,
hit the curb.
And when flying off into the fucking
woods went over and over and over and
over this habit.
So we called the cops immediately.
So the cops came down.
Same thing,
Bang.
The cops bounce off the curb and the
cops slam into the other cars.
Everybody,
yeah,
they were piling into each other and all
the cars are parked on the side of the
street.
They were all stuck.
They were all stuck and jammed and
fucked up.
Like some of them were like little
ditches and some of them were like in
the woods where the bushes were in shit
and they just kept coming.
Oh yeah.
Some people got through it.
Some people had some good skills.
Some people just slid with it and kind
of like straightened it out.
Yeah.
They managed to come down the hill not
too crazy.
Whoa.
That makes it more exciting.
You never know what's going to have.
Well,
I think the real,
the people that really fucked up,
they fucked up because they came down
the hill like they were driving.
They want to drive.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden,
oh fuck.
So if you're going 40,
50 miles an hour,
whatever the hell you were.
And then you hit that ice,
that's,
that's it,
bitch.
I'm like,
put the Nascar is going to do it makes
you think,
man.
Fuck living anywhere where it's that
cold.
We were talking about this before the
show,
um,
that,
uh,
there's a,
um,
a icebound fuel tanker in Alaska.
It stuck in the ocean.
Yeah.
The ocean is frozen around this fucking
boat and so they got to send a coast
guard ice cutter.
So the ice cutter is breaking the ice
around this Russian tanker and it's
Russian tankers just stopped there in a
just gigantic skating rink.
That's the ocean and it's just creeping
around pressing against the hall.
Did you imagine the trillions of pounds
over the.
Just be so scared.
Oh my God.
You're thinking it's going to pop.
The whole thing's gonna pop it.
I'm going to die.
I'm gonna die right here on the top of
this fucking frozen bullshit.
There was an episode from frozen tanker.
Really?
Yeah.
They got frozen and then some virus was
out to kill them.
Fuck that.
Returning old.
Super quick rate.
Oh,
with the virus.
That's what it was about.
Yeah.
So they had to drink regular water.
The only water they had was infected and
so it would make them turn old and I
couldn't get any worse.
They were frozen in.
There was no.
So what they do,
they got rescued right before the
got sent back.
Oh,
they get sent back to the regulates how
convenient.
Well,
they fed them regular water or say,
oh,
that's all it took.
We just need to get them saline.
You can reverse this fucking stupid
plot.
Who wrote that?
How dare you?
Whoever you are.
That was at the end of the x files when
they were basically just phoning it in.
I'm trying to think when that was.
I don't know.
Maybe it was like,
this isn't just to find something.
I don't know why they were out there.
That comes in time when some people just
fall it in certain amount of seasons.
Last we're done trying was why athletes
always post date.
They're giant contracts because like I
might get another contract.
I'm going,
I'm done working.
I'm not going to be 30 million million.
They get more money as,
as the contract goes on your contract.
So you're making like three times as
much in the 10th year as you were in the
first year.
Oh really?
Yeah,
but that's when you're going to be way
worse.
Sure.
Unless you're some crazy person that's
completely dedicated to always be in the
best ever.
You know.
How bad did Michael Jordan fall off
before he quit?
He didn't.
He did quit the first time he was mvp
level.
No,
not when he quit to play baseball.
When he quit,
quit,
quit.
Um,
when he came back he wasn't quite as
good.
Yeah,
he came back after that.
That's right.
Yeah,
he was bad.
Then he said he really hurt the wizards.
The bullets really because everyone sort
of stand around and watch him Jordan's
time.
So everyone else got worse.
Oh,
that's crazy.
That's funny.
So they got to give him the ball so much
jerry stackhouse and people had to like
watch him,
like he's got to be our first option.
I used to,
now I'm the second one.
I guess I'm just not as into it really.
That's fast and really heard the wizards
because they could have been like A.
I've gotten up one or two pick,
but instead he just came.
So they end up getting like eight or
nine pick.
So how long did he play with them for a
year?
Maybe two.
So that was that he took off the time
for baseball,
like one year you take baseball,
maybe two,
maybe one.
I'm not sure.
Why do we want to be like,
well,
my dad's on my last game.
His Dad got murdered.
Oh yeah.
I remember about the side of the road in
North Carolina.
What the fuck,
you know?
And then who's gonna buy the fucking
Hornets when they were still in
Charlotte.
But the owner got super juicy and greedy
about it and he was like,
if you buy it will be worth more.
So I don't want money on Michael Jordan
franchise.
What are you worth more so you gotta pay
more than this place is worth.
What kind of ridiculous fucking is that?
He lost it.
People are funny that way.
You,
you hear some ridiculous claims that
people wouldn't want,
you know,
the one thing sometimes it just makes
you just go,
what?
That's a pretty ridiculous one.
Reasonable that he brings that money to
anyone.
Then some people will just unreasonable
cousins.
Yeah.
You see David Cross on Conan O'brien
last night?
No.
What did you do it David Cross Jewish.
Um,
yeah,
uh,
he,
he was hilarious,
man.
He,
he was promoting,
one of the movies he did was chipmunks
too.
It's pretty out there.
Atheist though.
Yeah.
He was promoting chipmunks too and he
was just like bashing and don't fucking
go see
this movie.
And one of the producers like calling
out a producer and even called her out
as being a female.
He didn't even say her name and he goes,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
He just went off and then he started
saying,
you know what,
she has all the qualities of why people
when they say they hate Jewish people or
something like that or like,
like it was like so uncomfortable and
even cone and you could tell they edited
something right out of there because it
was like one of those weird cuts where
it's like,
let's talk about this other show,
you know,
Holy Shit,
it was weird.
I think you can watch it probably on
whatever cross does not strike me as an
angry God.
He was upset and I just ran into him at
the airport the other day was super
pleasant.
Oh No,
no.
He just seemed like he was pissed off at
somebody.
That's what I'm saying,
saying,
oh,
someone got him that riled up.
He be angry on
it was just doing it to separate himself
from the fact that he's doing shipwreck
mock all movies.
He said the movie,
that's what he's doing.
He said even the movie is a giant
commercial for whatever that,
that,
that a boat company is that they used in
the movie.
A boat company.
What's one of the cruise ships?
One of the cruise ships.
She's like,
it's just a big fucking commercial for
them anyways,
and,
and he just started going off on the
movie to that point where he's saying
the movies,
it's bullshit and it's much worse than
the monks.
But he also did.
It was beautiful.
It was love to see it coming from the
first one.
I chose to take the money but just like
shit on it.
Okay.
Right afterwards,
if it's funny,
is he shooting on it and being funny?
She's just joking around.
Call it up.
Yeah.
It was on last night.
I'm sure.
I read a thing on his website where he
had to defend himself when he was doing
it the first time that all these
hipsters were angry at him for doing the
chipmunks but that and like men in
black,
they were mad at him for that defend
himself.
What do you care?
He's just doing a little kid's movie.
Who gives a shit?
Yeah,
that shit on like Tim Allen for doing
like the Santa Claus and I'm like,
it's a fun scene.
Is a bunch of bullies who were picked on
when they were younger and they became
bullies.
There's not all.
I shouldn't say the whole scene.
It's not the whole scene.
It's part of the alternative scene is
the pointing fingers at people and
talking down about people and the
shitting on people.
You know,
there's a lot of people that are nice
people and I don't like the racks,
but they're nice and I like seeing them.
There's a lot of people that I like
seeing names.
Seven can.
I can name a few that I wouldn't do it
on the air.
It wouldn't be seven,
but it might be for,
that might be five.
Oh,
there's plenty of people you don't like.
A lot of those people you don't like at
all.
Yeah,
well they just,
you know,
there's annoying people.
But the,
the point is there's,
there's a certain,
uh,
in an it club,
you know,
being a part of it,
that scene,
the alternative scene and there's,
it's a very judgmental and sort of like
a bitchy little scene,
you know,
not,
I don't want to generalize completely,
but the idea that I always got was that
they were like the dorks in high school
and now they're powerful if the power,
but they're,
they're turning on other people the same
way people turned on them in high
school.
It's not as bad as I did now.
It's way better,
but it just seemed like there was a vibe
of that.
Bert Bert Kreischer told me a horrible
story once about a,
a bunch of alternative guy's being mean
to him.
And I was like,
you know,
like it's,
it's so stupid.
You know,
when,
when you see someone like our thing just
like saying Brooklyn's the best or
stockton's the bath,
if it's clearly not well,
you know,
there's just like saying our thing is
the people we run into are the best
comics in the world and it's like I'm
not other people that you randomly
didn't want it to.
I think it's also a thing where people
want confirmation that they're on the
right track and the best way to do that
is to shit on people.
We're on a different.
Got To make your team then most powerful
team.
Yeah.
What is that like?
People want you to be on their fucking,
your,
your cell phone provider.
They'll get mad if you're not still with
18 tea,
bro.
I thought you were smarter than that.
You're smarter than that because you
want to be a 100 percent right and all
your choices.
Yeah.
Right.
And you know,
in my neighborhood of arises,
not good.
It's a real difference.
It's really like a religious thing.
It's all the same shit.
We're fucked.
We're stupid.
We're stupid monkey.
That's supposed to have this kind of
power show fear.
That's the real issue or whatever they
want.
We're still supposed to be figuring out
consciousness.
We're,
we're,
we're not supposed to be working on
nuclear bombs at the stage.
You know,
we're way ahead of ourselves
technologically.
Right.
Brian,
what are you looking at Brian and trying
to get this clip for you.
It was when the song took your watch it
something have to fucking commercials.
Yeah.
That's just how it goes.
Now you can't watch a youtube clip
anymore.
You've got to watch some 30 seconds of
bullshit for and knowing God it.
And this is five minutes.
This was five minutes of commercials.
What's it's on team Coco's website.
Wait a minute.
You have five minutes with commercials
before you can watch them and I know you
get to watch like the first,
like $40 after 20 minutes or something
like that.
And then they make you watch like a five
minute commercial break.
So they make me do it.
They do it just like it's too well,
you can't find.
There's no youtube clips of that or Hulu
from.
Well,
I just have a feeling that the ones I
will find will cut off before,
I mean at least at least this is sort of
some sort of an alternative for them to
be able to advertise on videos and,
and promote these videos.
Getting out there.
I mean if you'll,
all you have to do is watch some 30
seconds clip here or there.
The South Park studios in between
breaks.
Do they like everyone's mother put a
32nd commercial.
Not much though.
And they have the kids cursing so it's
way better.
So Brian,
did you find it online anywhere else
other than the team?
Coco website.
Now I heard that uh,
that show was not doing very well
ratings wise.
Oh yeah.
Everyone's talking about Washington and
after people loved Conan O'brien when he
was on NBC in that time slot.
And for whatever reason why can't they
follow him?
Was why isn't it the same amount of
people?
I think some,
I guess you can Dvr,
but I feel like those people were,
I don't know,
people liked liking him.
They liked the idea of like in Conan,
but he would think he didn't
really watch when he was on earlier.
Really.
I mean,
they didn't watch.
You can blame it on a lead and all you
want,
but those people weren't.
The people weren't watching.
All my friends,
like,
that's way better than.
I'm like,
when's the last time you watched it?
It is a weird thing that they had the,
when they did that Jay Leno thing,
when they have the Jay Leno show at 10
tonight show at 11,
that was wonky.
That was a silly idea.
Got Everybody talking about it is.
Okay.
So it doesn't,
it doesn't,
it just professionally.
Worst thing that ever happened to you?
Yeah,
it's um,
it was just,
it was a miserable experience because
he's out to be in the movie.
I just,
um,
I had,
I was forced at legal point a to spend a
week on a cruise ship and I know you and
your family love going on cruises.
That's all we do.
I know,
I know.
So I'm not trying to never been on a
Chris Conan.
Stop it.
It's me.
All right.
Yes,
let's just say I love going on cruises,
fun time,
cruise,
and uh,
you know,
um,
so far it's,
how could they legally,
why were they legally want to make you
be on a cruise ship to know?
I don't know.
It was terrible.
It was.
There was no reason for me to be there.
If you,
if you see the movie and don't.
And I mean first of all,
shipwrecked.
It's a punk,
you know,
kids,
five-year-olds love puns.
They love it.
They love wordplay and,
and it,
it's a big commercial for a carnival
cruise lines is the entire movie.
Yes.
And,
and they thought,
won't it be fun?
They get David on there and uh,
and the scenes that take place on the
cruise ship,
I am always in a Pelican mascot.
Foam rubber outfit where you cannot see
any of my flesh,
nor do I have any dialogue.
Well,
wait,
if that's the case,
I'm sure you said to them,
get a stand,
Dan.
Get someone else to be in the foam
rubber costume and take them away on a,
on a cruise for.
Oh wait,
yes.
I tried that line of logic and reason,
but there was one producer who everybody
else had my back and the director was
like,
oh,
we don't,
that's fine.
We don't need them.
And I'm in the middle of Todd Margaret
too.
I was in London and,
and uh,
and,
and they're like,
no,
you have to go is more like,
and,
and um,
and there's this
one producer and I won't say who,
but she is the personification of what
people think about when they think
negatively about Jews
give.
You know what,
when people come here,
you're up.
No,
no,
I don't.
Your show the increasingly poor
decisions to todd.
Margaret,
very funny show you.
I'm sure you enjoy.
And then there was a cut where even
conant's arm like moved a little bit
other than the cut.
But I definitely saw how comfortable.
No,
I don't care.
Okay.
Yeah.
Wow.
That was a strong words.
But I wonder if he's really good friends
with the girl and he's just fucking
around.
Could be that.
It could be that he was good friends
with her and that was just a joke.
Bashing a movie that just was released
that that person is producing.
I doubt it.
Was He bashing the movie,
you don't see the movie.
And then he said it's just a big
commercial for Carnival cruise lines.
Well,
did they make him do the movies that.
What happened?
Was He contractually obligated to do the
second film?
I don't know.
He was just pissed about being on that
boat for a week.
Know that was a bit.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
It didn't offend me at all.
Yeah.
I mean the movie is.
The movie is if you don't say it's for
five year old,
he's a fun comic.
It's not for him.
He did a job and it's not,
it's not his Gig,
you know?
I'm just saying it was funny.
Yeah.
No it was.
When he's funny across.
He's fucking hilarious.
Um,
but yeah,
it probably sucks to be him and be one
of those movies and take all that
hipster shit.
Probably like Super Mad at him.
Dude.
You fucking totally sold out selling out
with the restaurant.
You know what?
I'm going to go look at it.
What is it?
He went off on a heckler than somebody
would like to alert.
I don't know.
It got weird and some from comic that
was there a up about it saying I was so
fucking weird.
Oh,
I did hear about that.
He was trying out some new material and
someone was filming him and he asked the
lady to stop filming them because he
didn't want it to get on the Internet,
which is there,
you know,
valid.
Especially because he was doing a free
show.
Do you ever just the bashing afterwards
he bashed Peter.
What did he say?
Just calling her fat and ugly.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
I don't know.
So I've got uncomfortable,
which is fine.
That was it.
Did you see it?
No,
my friend did.
He was there and he was like,
yeah,
I was super accountable.
You know,
you've got,
you've done it before where it's like,
oh,
I want you to harsh on this girl.
You know,
it's,
we're not 100 percent.
We're guessing like,
where's the line right now?
Well,
not only that,
you can be angry and lose your
composure.
A little girlfriend who just said
something that makes you fucking mad at
women or it could be the just the
seventh day in a row.
We've been heckled.
He can't get through your shit.
Who knows?
What was it?
The adjustable woman holding up the
camera was one girl.
She just had her thing.
She said,
oh,
sorry,
I'll delete it.
He's saying what you didn't see it was
her.
You have to look at it is what you're
saying.
Which he responded to this comic so that
you were fine.
It was well written and you're funny.
Comic,
some new girl.
He goes,
well you didn't see us when I asked her,
shut it off her roll her eyes and mouth
asshole to her friends.
Well,
you know,
I,
I see his point of view,
but I see her,
but she was there and she goes.
He goes,
yeah,
it's hard to do that.
That was after he was ripping into her,
like after she said,
I'm so sorry.
I'll turn it off.
Who knows?
I mean we're just commenting to be
there,
but I was talking about last night there
was like,
why?
What,
what?
Why do some people not able to just say
like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
it wasn't the,
that wasn't the best.
Well,
some people,
every one of them are wrong and it's
something never really young too.
It's okay.
Well,
it could be.
Who knows?
But we'd have to hear him talk about it
and talk.
I mean,
yeah,
we would have to actually see a video to
fucking tell the truth.
Really would to be able to decipher for
ourselves and I don't really get into
it.
Now.
Don't care at all.
Did you see what happened with Stan
Hope?
Well,
the kid stole his shit and was like
literally verbatim putting standup bits
on his blog.
Really if he's this fucking thing in
front of a camera.
No,
wrote it.
Wrote it on the little articles,
his blog entries.
Oh my God.
Stand up.
When I went after him with the power of
thor,
Stan hope went onto his,
uh,
his facebook page and posted in every
photo on his facebook page.
You're a fraud,
you know,
like little jokes about him being a
fraud.
Stan hope put it up on twitter.
So of course the swarms of human beings
who went to this guy's website and the
guy had comments up on his website and
his comments were just filled with
people saying,
you rip it off,
Doug Stanhope,
you fucking hack you this,
you that,
and just torturing this poor guy.
Stand up.
Did it for hours,
for hours.
He just had just fucking just going
after this poor fuck.
The guy apparently is a comic,
you know,
he just tries to,
tries to be Mr.
Cool Guy.
And yeah,
he tried to be Mr.
Cool.
Guy and steel.
Doug hopes material and pass it off as
his own getting tortured.
Oh my God.
He's done.
He had to pull his facebook the next
day,
his facebook and his blog.
We're both down screenshots of it all
and there's a facebook page all about
it.
I forget the name relates,
but page where it shows like,
you know,
like that could save the Stan hope wrote
on each photo instead.
Hope road,
some funny shit.
Well he,
his,
his dad.
I wonder how sad his father would be if
he knew his son was a fraud.
It's just standing up,
just kept going after the guy,
but the,
you know,
the guy's like so retarded.
Like the way he did it was so dumb.
Just copied a famous comedians work.
That's what you're going to do.
You know,
you want to come off as like a guy who
really mean.
Did you think that somehow or another no
one is going to be okay.
It's okay because people are reading it
instead of a college for the to pass
grades,
right.
I'll just copy someone else's work.
They can't do that anymore now because
if you have a file,
there's programs now that they can run
that file through and it'll recognize
plagiarism,
but I wasn't trying to say like,
like I didn't want any recognition for
what I've done.
Right.
Yeah,
of course.
You're just wanting to get out of your
situation.
You're just forced spot.
There's software now to just.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's software online software will
be.
They find duplicates of your work.
A teachers had that.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're fuck.
No.
My Buddy John Wilbert,
my,
my brother in law now I guess actually
brother in law's brother,
but he copied word for word out of cliff
notes one day and the teacher was like,
you copied this one because I can the
same exact paragraph does not a word
changed.
He just stuck to his story.
He was like,
nope.
Nope,
sure.
Didn't know I made that up.
Wow.
Because goes this entire paragraph.
There's not a word changed.
Well,
you know,
if he's,
if he's that confident.
Nope.
What kind of a teacher is that?
It was,
it was one of the nondual teachers be
bused in.
Oh,
one of the non Jewish teacher.
So they couldn't hang.
I think eventually she was like,
fine,
whatever.
What was it like?
Just they couldn't deal with the Jewish
men.
Well,
it was probably like,
look at this Brat.
He refused to admit it.
I don't give a shit then fucking copy
for the rest of your life.
But the Jewish teachers would come down
on you for sure.
Like that.
Is that what you said?
Non Jewish Jewish.
The non Jewish ones we just didn't
respect.
Really?
Yeah,
they just didn't have our.
How can we could run over them.
I don't know.
There was some teachers use all agreed.
We're not going to respect you really
year after year.
Everyone makes the same agreement.
Nobody talks about it.
There's some teachers like you don't
fuck with rabbit Krakauer.
Yeah.
What was that man?
What is it that some kids just like
certain teachers and everybody gets
along great.
I don't know.
It might be like hidden like nonverbal
cues are giving out or you know,
I have no idea.
There's weak teachers,
strong teachers.
They all the same curriculum to teach
what that is.
Got To be the biggest fucking problem
with this country.
It's got to be the biggest problem is
how kids go to school,
the education system,
you know,
coming out of it with your fucking head
together and try to decipher all the
nonsense stupidity and programming and
the idea that you know,
no one ever gets pushed into our field.
No one ever.
No one ever says,
you know what are.
You're always cracking jokes in class.
You're a funny guy.
You obviously need attention.
If you had thought about going to an
open mic night,
no one's ever said that to you.
Have you thought about maybe being a
standup comedian?
Yeah.
No.
You have to get some job somewhere.
Some jobs do stupid when you were doing
it for a little while.
There's still a come on.
How much longer?
The preparation for a shit existence.
That's the worst part about it,
man.
The worst part about it is it kind of
breaks your soul when you go through
shit,
boring classes in school,
it breaks your soul for the idea that
you're prepares you for the idea that
you're always gonna.
Have let a teacher.
He taught modern American lit and his
deal was this.
He goes,
you will never have to know anything
about what Joseph Conrad wrote.
What you were learning here with a
bachelor of arts is how to get reports
done on time.
Whoa,
because that's it.
That's all you're learning.
Jesus.
You're not gonna have to apply any of
this fitzgerald.
When is that going to come in your
regular life?
Never.
We're gonna have to learn.
When I say 9:00
on Tuesday,
have it on my desk,
that's all they're preparing you for.
Why is right on really large degree.
Yeah.
He is a ride for sure.
I mean that is what ultimately it is
the,
that's what's getting measured,
you know?
Yeah.
You can't measure how much you're
learning.
You measure how much,
how well you're doing on tests and how
much effort you're putting into your,
your paper.
Are there measurements supposed to be.
You're just were lazy as fuck.
We want to make sure you're doing your
work and not only that,
it's not just about educating people.
It's about educating people and
preparing them for work,
you know,
because that's really what it's all
about and there's a certain amount of
discipline that you're just not going to
have.
How would you feel to get it like a
creative kid and nurture them from the
start?
Fucking hard man.
The schools really.
I mean they know they have art,
right?
Well,
you know,
we gotta we boxed ourselves into a bad
situation as a species,
as a race,
as a,
as a civilization,
because we need a lot of people doing
shit that sucks.
Oh yeah.
It's not like as a child,
like you're groomed into a world of
happiness and prosperity and fulfillment
and know there's a lot.
There's a maze and there's a fucking
million pitfalls and million jobs that
you can get into that I'm not going to
be satisfying to you.
You need to have to figure your way
through those.
We need people.
We need someone.
We need war machines,
different.
Meet him.
When you're trying to explain to them
why they're wrong or misguided,
you realize they're so stupid.
I don't.
I have to rethink how I'm going to
express this to you.
Well,
the stuff that you've done,
some people just don't have enough
information in their head and they,
you know,
their,
their view of the world is very limited.
I've met very few stupid people have met
a lot of uninsured.
I shouldn't say I met very few people,
but much more.
More people are uninspired than our
stupid.
There's definitely stupid people though.
It must be like explaining stuff.
Your kid now,
because kids get things,
kids get things,
they don't have anything.
No kids get things and they bring it up
the next day.
They have questions about the next day,
like they're pondering an idea the kit.
It's not.
Yeah,
they don't have any prior programming
that you have to fuck with.
The real problem is a person who grew
their whole life and,
and,
and in their mind developed.
It's ridiculous.
Just stuck and I'm like,
you know,
you get some poor guy who was a fucking
fundamentalist Christian,
one of those crazy speaking in tongues
guys,
you know,
and at 40 years old he's just starting
to branch out on his own and escape is
his former family.
What are the guys last chances?
Good luck being able to do it because
yeah,
if you.
But if you got that guy when he was a
baby and brought them up in a reasonable
household where people are logical and
loving and kind of like gave him a sort
of a,
a helpful boost,
but let them know,
hey man,
this is a crazy world and nobody
understands it.
They play with close to the people you
love and enjoy yourself if you can,
you know,
it was really say with autistic kids
like early to get them to more normal as
you can make them really,
you got to get them fully set in
patterns.
There's something to do with autistic
kids and you know,
whatever it is that's causing that.
And there has to be.
I mean,
it's a very unpopular opinion,
but there has to be something to do with
autistic kids and the next stage of
human evolution.
What do you mean has to be.
Because there's so many people that are
[inaudible].
So many people that have autism or
development or thought.
I think what they're experiencing with
these people were experiencing for
whatever reason because of their
disease,
um,
what,
you know,
and not,
not all of them can do this,
but the few that can,
there's so many of them.
There's so many super genius autistic
kids.
I mean,
there's a million videos.
You can look at them,
I'm exaggerating obviously,
but there's a lot of videos you can go
online and there's the one kid that we
talked about that can look out the
window of a plane and draw the exact
scene perfectly.
I mean,
he could just memorize things.
There's,
there's people that can do very,
very complex mathematics at a really
young age.
There's a kid that's a,
he's got something like asperger's or
something and he says this incredible
composer.
He's composed like five symphonies and
he's like 11 years old or something,
nuts,
asperger's and things out of the store.
And all he does is make it socially
uncomfortable for everyone.
Well,
maybe it's no one ever put a fucking
pair of drumsticks and that kids.
And maybe you get that motherfucker on a
drum kit,
but I,
I,
when you see something that's hyper
human and it's also attached to a
disease belt webbing for Walter World,
right between their toddlers and shit's
moving forward.
Yeah,
I mean I wonder,
I wonder what it is,
but when you see people capable of
incredible feats and they also have this
incredible emotional and psychological
impairment,
you know,
this inability to communicate and
connect with people or what,
or whatever it is that they have,
whatever,
you know,
personal kink they have.
But to also have this superpower that's
a,
it's amazing man.
It's amazing when you watch those shows,
like whenever they have like an a and e
show or something,
when they feature a bunch of people who
can do like ridiculous shit.
You know,
there's,
there's some people that literally are
another thing.
They're like,
they have a little bit of the new thing
in them,
you know,
and I wonder how many more of them we
have now than just 100 years ago.
You know,
I wonder how many more people are born.
I mean there's obviously like super
geniuses always.
There's always been guys like Tesla,
you know,
and,
and Stephen Hawking and due to that
nature alive.
Yeah.
That's crazy,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Just people will go fuck them up.
It's not like it came out feeling fine.
Yeah.
But like he's still alive.
He's alive and making computations with
his fingers.
That no idea.
When I heard about patrice not being
able to talk before he went,
it was like,
oh,
that's,
that's who he is.
That's everything I know about him.
It revolves around his mouth.
Yeah.
That's horrible.
This guys figured out a way to do
something.
Wow.
Keep it going to keep it going.
He,
you ever seen his fingers move?
He knows and he clicks on this thing and
he can kind of moves and,
and chooses words from this screen.
It's really amazing.
It's amazing that all that junk.
I don't know.
That's a good question.
I don't think so.
Oh yeah.
Don't want to downplay the wonder.
I wonder what keeps a dude like that
moving on because there has to be some
form of enjoyment for him as well.
He must be enjoying some something
about.
Yeah,
his science career,
you know,
your clear like biological imperatives
is
to continue life,
so he's like,
I have to have some reason to do that.
Stay alive.
Yeah,
it must be.
It must get fulfillment out of it.
Finding out new show or writing a book,
just like anybody want a strange
situation man.
To be trapped in your body like that and
doing computations with your fingers and
this thing.
Click,
click,
click.
Whose phone is next to the computer?
Because the thing keeps going.
Take to the addicted it.
Is it your phone Brian next to your
computer,
right?
Yeah.
It's not the computer.
There is nothing to do with the sound.
You sure?
Yeah.
Well it doesn't sound.
Come through that computer have
completely muted.
It's completely muted.
I don't think it has to do with the
mute.
I think it's the electricity doesn't
radio.
Sometimes it's not the matter of the
computer being muted.
It is because you have the phone next to
the computer.
It's like picking up a signal.
Yeah.
It's not a mute thing.
It's not like it's coming through like
a,
like a sound so that when you're
shooting sometimes they'll turn your
phones off or on mute off.
We were getting feedback.
Yeah.
It goes d to d,
two to.
It'll do it in your car sometimes too.
There's an illegal right nearest area.
If you have like a stereo for where your
cds or something didn't leave it there.
It'll.
It's real close.
It'll find through how fucked is that
man?
How far does this signal that's having a
war inside your car have the battle and
for dominance and meanwhile these were
all bouncing around and the reason they
tell you to turn your phones off on the
plan?
Is that it?
I think so because if everyone's doing
that,
it could really come through it.
Make sense?
Phones make sense or what doesn't make
sense?
Like ipods.
That doesn't make sense.
That seems silly,
but you know what?
Whatever.
I think it's an.
It's an exercise in getting people to
pay attention to rules.
It's just like moving your seat just to
get you ready for the.
For the otherwise.
How.
How do three older women control an
entire full of people?
It's like,
listen,
I want to fall asleep now.
I don't want to turn it back on.
I'm going to listen to music the whole
time.
Can I just fall asleep with it in?
Can't gonna kill us all.
I got caught on that.
Easy to kill people.
If all you gotta do is like,
keep an ipod on the plane would fall out
of the fucking sky.
I don't know.
The ultimate.
His little jokes.
That's what happened to space shutter
space shuttle.
All Jewish couple in the back.
I had the tray table down for the kosher
meal and now you cannot take off with
the kosher meal.
Tray down.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing that you could
actually even tell people that if you
had your phone on it could be in danger.
Like,
well,
let's fix that.
Fix that.
You know,
those 83 ads.
There was an article today.
I think I retweeted it.
Those,
uh,
eight,
three ads are showing cracks on the
wings.
Really?
Yeah.
Ones are built.
How long?
I'll tell you right now.
Well,
there's apparently there's a,
one of them was a quantas jet and two
other ones.
Where you.
Yeah,
with you.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
World's biggest super jumbo jets must be
grounded.
Say engineers after cracks or founded
the wings of three Airbus a three,
eight s cracks are some of the worst
things you can find me.
Yeah.
I would say to Singapore Air Super
Jumbos and one quantas.
Both
Airlines admit the cracks,
but say the planes are safe.
What is their quote?
Oh God,
are you out of your mind?
This is amazing.
This is a huge fucking planes.
When Ari and I flew in it,
it's like flying in a giant apartment
building.
That's weird.
There was like we sat in the front and
there was a second floor we could like
go upstairs to the bar,
so there's actually a bar that you can
sit at the bar.
There's a bar.
That's cool.
Yeah.
There was a bar and they had like
magazines out and shit and they would
just serve you food or drink whatever
you wanted the entire time you're there.
It was ridiculous.
It's the,
the,
the thing that you get in first class is
like,
it's like an apartment.
It's huge,
it's enormous.
It spins your seat,
spins like it goes straight if you want
to lie down or he turned sideways and it
can be like a lazy boy and then you have
this big ass flat screen tv in front of
you.
I mean it's ridiculous and the food is
really fucking good.
It's like most airline food sucks,
but like,
like Quantas firstclass fucking good
meals,
man.
It's Yummy food and you're 30,000
feet above the ocean hurling through the
sky in a metal tube.
It ain't like south west eight course
tasting menu they had.
It was so delicious and great man.
You Got Pajamas?
Yeah.
You get pajamas.
Toothpaste.
Shit.
I turned it off on the plane.
Did you really?
Here's what you got to do because the
pot is not completely enclosed.
So if any rich people listening,
you don't turn your body towards.
I'm a way.
I mean from the,
from the opening,
you have to turn towards it because
you're always worried.
Like somebody might be coming up.
We turn so you can see them come through
the netting,
right,
because they could see down there
beating on her,
beating off to put my head by where my
dick would be.
I looked at the lady behind me,
like who could get an angle at it?
She was asleep,
so I was like,
okay.
How much time do you think you took?
Probably probably it was probably a
little longer.
Probably like two to four minutes to
four minutes.
Were you furious or thought?
And then we'll stop.
You have real gentle,
but based on the lefthand and jerker on
that with the right does,
you were doing,
you know,
because I was on the right side of the
plane.
It's probably good for your core as
well.
Just put yourself in that way.
We'll just,
you don't fall over.
And then would you shoot it into your
Pajama tops?
No,
uh,
I shot it into the um,
the slipper socks,
like if you turn one of those inside out
and shot it into it.
And then a horse,
like a peasant to use my regular socks.
I was on a plane once with Melanie
Griffith and we're flying to England.
She was sitting right in front of me and
there was a dude who was right beside
her and you know how when planes in the
first class cabin there seats don't line
up like everyone's not head to toe.
They're kind of staggered because of
these big ass pods.
Well,
the way it was staggered was Melanie
Griffith head lined up directly with
this fat guys asked,
was right across the aisle no more than
a couple of feet away.
Her head directly lined up with his ass
and he unloaded this dude unloaded in
the middle of the flight.
One of the most horrific hate like farts
are friend tate.
Fletcher is known for having the most
ferocious far.
It's because pizza big giant dude and he
takes a lot of protein powder and when
you eat a lot of protein like your body,
like rid of it because it's kind of a
process.
That extra shit.
Well,
and it turns into farts.
And this dude just.
I mean,
I don't know what he ate,
but he was a big guy and by the way,
I don't even know if it was his fault
because it's not like I have a fucking
locator,
but if you're on a plane and there's a
fart and you see a fat guy,
that guy gets blamed.
He blamed you,
gets blamed more than like black kids
get blamed for stolen things.
Fad people get blamed for farts on
planes.
Always like,
that's like the first person you look to
like,
fuck yeah,
it was him and the way it lined up,
it was just his ass was just right
across from her face.
It was horrific,
man.
I mean it was a.
It was a nightmare.
Fart.
And what are the odds in life that you
would ever have your face or Melanie
Griffith face that close to your ass.
You could unload on her face like that
on her face.
I talked about it on stage that night in
England because it was so ridiculous
because I just.
It was just such a preposterous lineup.
What I can never turn it into a bit,
but it was really hilarious at the time.
I just,
I couldn't imagine.
Well,
and I was thinking,
what if this guy had planned this out?
What I feel like came to melanie
griffiths agent and he said,
listen,
I'd be willing to pay a million dollars
to fart and ms Dot Griffin.
I'm like,
you're out of your fucking mind.
You know,
we can't bring your offer to her.
Bring it to them and they wouldn't do
that.
Then the agent said,
listen,
I think we can work something out.
I've been looking at how these planes
line up and this is what I want to show
you.
Look at it.
Here's your seat.
Here's Melanie Griffith.
See,
look when you're acerbate liquid.
We got.
I think we got it.
I think we got a melody.
Doesn't even have to know.
Is that a little unethical to keeping
the money from Melanie?
I mean that's part of my thrill.
Well,
you know,
I'll just slip it into her bank account.
No,
he doesn't have to know.
I just a little extra money in her bank
account and it just opened his ass on
Melanie's head was hot.
It was a hot far for sure.
There was some heat to it.
That was one way.
You might not have known how bad it was
before you let it go,
but once you let it go,
you realized how atrocious what a
terrible person you are,
but you should be despised.
Think about all the shit particles from
your ass and people were forced to
acknowledge and their nostrils word,
word or we have one of those crazy
positive Brazil.
I don't know.
I don't know what it's going to be like.
Oh,
he's going to Brazil with me.
We're going to party.
You're going to party in Rio.
Apparently it's the nuttiest crowd for
mma ever.
Like you've never seen a more brilliant
and they're all broadly on the car.
Lot of Brazilians in the card and a good
ones.
Who some are.
Paul Perez is fighting.
That's a fucking great fight,
man.
That's going to be interesting and it
must go nuts for it.
Although fighting Chad Mendez,
man,
I wouldn't want to be Chad Mendez in
Brazil.
She's Christ.
Although,
although in Anderson,
you know,
like heroes,
there are heroes.
There are heroes.
Well,
there are two of three.
I mean it's really.
There's no country like Brazil man,
where there's three UFC champions.
I mean,
Zoe,
how many weight classes now?
There's 35.
40th five.
Fifty five.
Seventy,
85.
Two.
Oh,
five and heavyweight.
So there's seven weight classes and
three of them are dominated by
Brazilians.
Wow,
that's amazing.
I don't have that in Americans.
What's that?
Don't have as many Americans know.
George St Pierre who is one 70.
But then meg diaz and Carlos condit to
Americans are going to be fighting for
the interim belt.
So that's kind of why.
Oh,
and Tom Pill.
Well,
it's means a lot because George is out
for a long time.
He's nice blown.
He had to get surgery.
He had to get a job.
You never can tell a tendon graph.
It's a big surgery.
The patella tendon graft is a really
difficult one.
The way they do that,
it's a long road to recovery.
You have to.
They take a chunk of bone out of your,
your kneecap and a chunk of bone out of
your Shin and they sliced the Patella
tendon,
they take a piece of it off and they use
that piece to recreate the acl,
the anterior cruciate ligament that's
inside the middle of the need of
stabilizing ligaments.
So then they have to screw that in
place.
They have to drill holes and then they
have to take a little piece of bone we
took from your kneecap and stuff and
into your bone stuff into your,
you know,
your humorous.
Is that what it is?
What's the Femur?
Femur.
Seven in your femur and then they
stuffed it into the lower one to
whatever your shin bone is.
Yeah.
It's gnarly shit for a long time.
Forever.
What have you had?
Well,
that is actually a technique that
they've been using for a long time.
The patella tendon graft that more than,
more than 20 years because I hadn't done
a Patella tendon graft done in the
nineties.
I had done,
I believe it was 93.
I had it done.
Um,
but now they are more and more likely or
use,
um,
a graph from a dead person.
I have in my right knee.
A cadaver graft.
Yeah.
They use the Achilles tendon.
Is He really doing new plastic news?
Artificial knees?
He has no cartilage in his knees either
one,
zero.
Our friend Sean rouse has a crazy form
of arthritis.
It's like super aggressive arthritis and
still happen now.
I'm sure they might have gotten bumped
up.
Yeah.
Obviously,
like I know a guy who works at whatever.
So what are they?
Gonna you know how they do them and they
have to cut your knee off.
Yeah,
he's got pretty much nothing.
You ever seen how they do hip
replacements?
Gnarly,
dude.
They take the socket out,
they cut it off,
they saw it off and they put a new
socket in there and drive it into your
fucking bone.
Screw this bolt into your bone.
And now you have this new ball and
socket set up in your head.
That's probably 100 times better than
the original.
Yeah.
Well,
I want to get everything replaced.
Sort of know because it's like it's also
an alien piece.
It will.
It will start to resolve after about 15
years,
which is totally fine for him,
but he goes off to where just into my
body.
Well after 15 years and so then they go
back and replace it 15 years ago.
They probably have
amazing ones.
Maybe probably they'll probably have one
that's better than the human knee when
you would think with the lightweight
materials and if they could figure out
something that's way better
biocompatible surgeries just because
like I don't need it,
but fuck it.
Well if you've seen that dude who he's
got no legs,
he lost his legs and he's competing in
races with these artificial legs.
He lost his legs below the knee and so
they put the spring things.
Yeah,
these crazy fucking things and he.
It actually,
it's like kicking ass with these things,
man.
He could run fast and some people are
actually saying like this is an unfair
advantage.
Like you can't say that man.
Dude gets his legs cut off springs on
his leg though,
but they still running down unless he's
breaking world records.
You got to deal with that shit.
As long as it gets closer,
it's okay.
Yeah.
Unless he's breaking world records.
That would be incredible.
The humanity of guys started getting
their legs cut off so that they could
run as fast as him and getting these
artificial feet screwed on somebody to
make these skates and whether they would
do is speed skates.
They would come slightly apart from the
skate as you were stepping up,
so they'll give you an extra split.
Second of ice time if it's touching the
ice.
The blade,
the like slowly removed from your shoe.
Staying a little longer and all those.
I think it was.
I think it was Swiss.
I don't know.
They're all fucking shattering records.
Jesus Christ just from doing that.
Yeah.
Is that amazing?
Clever little monkeys.
You know.
Clever little monkeys figure that out.
I remember this last past a Olympics
with a dude died on the.
Bob Forgot.
Gnarly man.
That's why I'm a huge proponent of
everyone should have to wear a helmet.
Karen's.
Yeah.
Everyone to know that that's possible.
We need to know that that's possible.
You know,
that's,
that's not something you should keep
from people.
People that are considering being a
bobsled person could die from this.
Everyone was saying how it was way too
fast,
was running way too fast.
Well,
you look at what they're doing,
man,
so fast flying in those fucking things
and I guess somehow or another you're
steering with your weight,
correct?
Yeah,
I think so.
I mean,
you must be doing something if they
needed to turn.
Right,
right.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Damn,
there was a dude who was a fighter.
He fought a todd hayes.
He fought in valley to,
in Japan and uh,
he was supposed to fight Hixon Gracie,
but he blew his shoulder out in the
fight before that he won.
And um,
he uh,
quit fighting and to become a bobsled
guy.
Really?
Yeah.
That was just Walkerton bobsledding for
awhile.
Did he totally mixed one gold when they
started,
they started rethinking it.
They were like,
oh,
we don't need bobsledders.
We need to fucking track people.
We need people that are fucking fast and
strong to push the Basic Osha Walker
made them win.
The goal you,
I think he wants something,
probably not the goal.
That sounds ridiculous.
Walker,
that's a bad motherfucker,
dude.
He made the cowboys.
He's like 47 or 48 years old now and
he's still fighting mma.
A fondant,
fondant.
Strikeforce twice.
At least twice in one.
Dude.
He's fucking show readed.
He's ridiculously shredded.
Really?
Oh my God.
He's 48 years old and he apparently has
like super human discipline.
Never lifted a weight that you put.
Well he says that,
but then other dudes say that he has
lifted weights,
has.
Well,
no.
He also has a multiple personality
disorder,
so he could be saying that he's not
lifting weights and he's telling the
truth because he's not lifting weights.
But Clyde is in Clyde's the one that has
the past 24 hours,
but I think I'm pretty sure I don't want
to talk out of school,
but I'm pretty sure I read on his
website that he has trauma related
multiple personality disorder from
football.
Yeah.
And I read that and I was like,
wow.
Well why is this guy fighting in mma
then?
You know,
that seems crazy that he would go from
that to fighting and mma,
but the fights that he's had to,
he's just mauled people.
He's such a fucking super athlete.
If Hershel Walker was around for mma,
was around when Herschel Walker was
young when he was.
Yeah.
If he,
if he had decided to do that.
He's,
there's every now and then there's dudes
that can just throw people around.
They just,
they're just so dominant for a little
while.
The Vikings pretty much true to their
whole team.
For him it was like everybody that had
good at draft picks for the next five
years while we want to map back to.
Well,
that's a super athlete,
man.
It made the cowboys for so long.
Yeah.
Did you hear me?
Whether he wants to fight,
pick,
pack man now?
Yeah,
because he's going to jail.
Oh,
is that why?
Yeah,
the judge,
the judge will let him a postpone his
jail time until June.
So if he can get pack you out of fight
him in May,
he'll make a shitload of money and then
go to jail for 90 days.
So since the judge has allowed him to
postpone and he's like,
all right,
fuck it,
let's go after a fight.
Let's go fight problem.
No,
it will not be a lame fight.
Pacquiao was a killer.
But I think that um,
a lot of people feel that patio was
exposed a little bit by Marquez.
Now while I'm in,
I'm all Marquez fight that they've had
three fights now and that,
uh,
you know,
mark has felt like he won two of those
and uh,
you know,
it wasn't,
not nearly the dominant victory that
pack out hope for.
So a lot of people I think are thinking
that of floyd mayweather.
It was scared of him before.
Now he's like relaxed now he saw the way
Martin shot.
Yeah,
because he,
he box the shit out of Marquez when they
fought.
Floyd didn't even take any damage.
Floyd Mayweather.
It's just technically and strategically
on another level.
The thing about pack les packy out is
he's a,
he's a beast.
He's got crazy power in his hands,
ridiculous speed,
and he can catch anybody.
And if he,
if he tees off on floyd and he gets a
good rhythm and starts coming at him
with those wild combinations,
anything can happen.
But Floyd doesn't feel like he could do
that.
Floyd.
Things that could stop them.
Now he's doing one on.
I don't know if I had a gamble.
It's hard to bet against Pacquiao
because pack has been fighting.
He's been fighting big guys too.
When he fought,
you know when,
when he fought flux is named Margarito.
He'd beat the shit out of Margarita.
Margarita was way bigger than him.
And Margaret is a dangerous guy.
He fucked Margarito up,
you know?
I mean he broke his eye socket.
He broke his orbital,
made him.
He has an artificial lens in his eye
now.
Margarito does because of that fight.
Yeah.
I was 15,
16 pounds lighter than him.
Easily.
Maybe even more.
It might've been 18 pounds during fight
time because they weigh him on Hbo.
They way on the day of the fight too.
And they see how much it guys rehydrated
and they show you that statistic,
which I think is brilliant.
The UFC should probably incorporate
something like that too,
but I don't think they wanted to meant
how much.
Yeah,
some guys are cutting like guys like
Anthony Johnson,
the other Chatam,
Anthony Johnson's fight and Vito Belfort
this weekend in Brazil that's going to
be fucking car and he's fighting at one
85 for the first time to which for
Anthony's,
the right move if you've never seen
Anthony Johnson before,
he's another specimen or specimen
through a specimen and he's a big one
70,
like the biggest possible and he would,
I would see him walking around like in
between fights and it was well over 200
pounds.
It was enormous.
He looked like a heavyweight,
you know,
and then he would drop.
He said at one point in time he cut 60
pounds to make,
to make one 70 a long time.
I mean I'm sure he did it over a long
camp but starved themselves.
60.
It was up to like 2:30.
I know exactly.
Meanwhile with him was mostly muscle.
You know it.
Most of them Meghan's body eat itself.
You dehydrating and eat itself.
I mean,
he's losing a little bit of fat,
but he's not a fat guy.
It doesn't get fat.
It's just an athlete.
Let's fucking brutal man.
It's like the a point of diminishing
returns and I can't do that because of a
brain damage.
That's when it's.
Most people are most susceptible to
brain damage.
Then you won't cut it like they would.
They would.
They would cut anyway.
Yeah,
they cut anyway.
They always do.
They used to have a wait.
They used to have it in boxing.
They used to have the day of,
but more people die of brain injuries
because of dehydration.
What happened after the fight?
I don't think in the old days the box.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter if she lives all
weight during fight alone.
Take a lot of people were hip to a ivs
back in the day either.
So when they would lose weight,
when they would lose weight,
no.
No eyeballs to replenish.
To put your liquids back in.
That's the best way to look.
So weak.
When are the winds are death?
I've seen guys looked.
Terrified.
Think.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Breath is horrible.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean they don't eat for,
you know,
they don't eat for a long time before
they get up there.
A lot of the guys except the
heavyweights heavyweights,
they're.
I love their jeans.
Fuck it.
About the same,
but there's a few guys that have had to
cut weight at heavyweight.
Tim Sylvia had a cut weight once he
waiting over.
I remember that he was over to 65.
Brock's always made the weight cuts.
He cuts to that.
Yeah.
If he,
if he wanted to,
he gets about 300 pounds if you want to
do.
I'm sure we started packing on the Korea
team doing power lifting and shit like
that and eating all day,
but I don't think he can eat all day now
because of that.
A stomach thing I think is diet.
It's got to be very different.
That's not just time,
dude.
He had diverticulitis.
You could die from that shit,
man.
People die.
It's amazing.
I never even heard of that before he got
it.
I never heard of that.
It should rename it.
Okay.
Brock Lesnar's disease,
same way.
Lou Gehrig had all the time that you and
I have been to Fogo de Chao,
all of those Brazilian steakhouses who
would've ever thought that someone could
die from eating too much meat.
That's when you have ever thought of
that.
We've been going to those places for a
decade.
Got To get to the wind in Brazil.
Fuck Ya know the ones in Brazil or even
better because they serve like chicken
hearts and stuff that people in America
are kind of scared of.
That shit's delicious,
dude.
With when we went to one in Sao Paulo,
it was one of the best ones I've ever
been to ever,
and they just kept giving us these
chicken hearts.
I was like,
dude,
keep coming with them.
Chicken hearts.
Ooh.
It's like salted.
They know how to cook.
Do is grill in Israel.
This just a wild culture,
man.
It's a beautiful culture.
The culture of Brazil is so fun,
you know,
meat and fighting and the girls are
beautiful and they're living on the
beach ass and everybody's doing a play
in Jujitsu.
I mean it's like,
wow,
what a,
what a crazy culture man.
And soccer and everything,
you know,
and their,
their economy has changed in a big way
over the last few years.
Apparently they found oil off the shore
and their economy's booming.
Leaders,
the leaders of the world in aids
research and,
and uh,
and um,
education.
Really.
Yeah.
So a lot of places in Rio also I've
heard where people go to get a good but
cheap plastic surgery can see that.
Yeah,
like a girls in Hollywood that can't
afford going to doctors here.
You can fly to Brazil and get their shit
done their time and stuff I guess.
And then you know,
then you just chill out and Rio,
chill on the beach while your tits.
He'll get on a plane and head home like
I want to vacation.
Came back with tits.
I'm excited to hold another culture.
Just don't go to the favelas looking for
heroin,
keep it together and don't get bit by a
Brazilian watering spider.
Does a Brazilian wandering spider that
kills you.
And one of the things that happens is
the people that survive,
first of all,
you will.
You will have a 24 hour raging death.
Hard on.
Really?
Yes.
Yeah.
The way it affects your body.
It apparently blasts your levels of
nitric acid and nitric oxide,
which is,
uh,
the same thing.
That was the same effect that Viagra has
like and with this stuff does,
is just make your dick hard as fucking
cold steel to the point where it's
painful.
When your Dick is dying,
it's expanded so hard that it's tearing.
Literally the cells are ripping apart
from each other.
It's getting so big and so hard that the
cells are separating from each other,
tearing in agony,
in screaming pain,
and this is happening to all your
muscles.
Not just your cock,
but every muscle in your body.
It's just in mad agony.
And if you survive and most people
don't,
but if you survive,
you'll be fucked.
You'll be dead.
You might as well be dead.
You.
Dick won't work anymore.
It's done forever.
Your body is going to be a rack.
You're going to be physically a wreck.
All your muscles are going to be.
So wait,
did they?
Did they.
Once you get bit what happens to,
can you go to the doctor immediately or
almost immediately?
Almost immediately.
You're fucked.
There's no.
I don't.
I don't know if they have a.
What would you say percentage wise?
Are you worried about the spider?
Me.
I'm not going to the jungle.
Oh,
said word.
I hope it's only in the jungle shit.
I'm pretty sure it's only in the jungle.
Yeah,
but if I want to put myself in a fucking
boy in the plastic bubble suit,
dress up like man,
I don't know.
I,
I'm not really worried about it.
I hotels it is down there.
Beautiful hotels.
Pretty much everyone where they ever
have tourists from other places.
Like the Nice hotels are nice
everywhere.
Yeah.
And any city in the world.
It's a real city.
They're going to have some nice places
to stay even in,
you know,
I mean I've seen like Kuwait,
Kuwait has beautiful,
beautiful hotels and you know,
it's Kinda crazy.
You would think someone would just went
to war with Iraq just a few years ago
and probably be a mess right now.
Right now that really grow there.
It's beautiful.
I had a crazy dream.
I just,
I quit pot and I,
my dreams went nuts.
He tells me.
Tell us about that because how long did
you quit it for?
Thirteen days.
Wow.
But I'm an everyday,
multiple times a day smoker.
Um,
I heard that you get dreams or
nightmares after three days.
Nightmares.
Yeah.
So I was trying to put three days to try
to get the dream,
the nightmare to see what would happen
if you quit.
But it took me,
it took me two years.
We need to give you some Alpha brain.
I've been out for brand would give you
some ridiculous.
A lot of people kept saying like,
oh,
it must be the Alpha brain or whatever
it was you really vivid dreams.
We don't.
It's a combination of all the,
the neutral bigs and the B six.
And because B,
six on its own apparently can do that.
A lot of the neutral box on their own
can give you some weird dream effects.
But apparently all of them together with
the [inaudible] really kicks it was
every night.
Definitely did mushrooms.
Every night I would get the crate like
plot-driven dreams,
like long and clear,
like a member of the for way longer.
Well,
I'm,
one of them was I was dropping the
jungle in Brazil and there was all these
dangerous predators,
but there's also tons of mushroom
spores.
So we were like,
dude,
I think it's good to stop smoking pot
for a little bit.
I think it's good to stop doing
everything brick.
I take meat breaks,
I take breaks where I'll eat like
vegetables for like a couple of hours a
little bit.
Just for the fuck of it.
I just do it if I feel like doing it.
Like sometimes like there's a,
a good Vegan restaurant in your hair and
every now and then I'll just have this
like real hankering for some like real
vegetable heavy food.
Sounds good.
What are you saying when you mean why?
Ken?
Why?
What does that Fagan food can?
Well,
Ken.
Wow.
Oh keenwah in that,
um,
that grain that you know,
heavy protein grain of the whole foods
salad bar.
I got a bunch of different types of
cameras.
Yeah.
So this is the only plant.
Apparently that has all the amino acids
that.
Yeah,
that I think soil.
So I don't think so.
I don't think Soi has everything really.
Yeah.
And so it makes you grow up.
Tits fucks away.
So I made Brian cry like Almond Almond
milk is great for you.
I love that.
I drink that shit every day.
I'd say that's pretty much substituted
my Mo.
Most of my dairy,
unless I'm having cookies,
it's just the habit.
It's really easy to Make by yourself.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Almond milk you can make because he had
the vitamix.
It's really cool for that reason just to
mix it with water,
but there's a lot of good recipes online
to make.
Like do you make it?
I tried it once and it worked.
So.
So do you have to soak the almonds
first?
Is that okay?
Yeah.
Soak it overnight for 24 hours and then
mix it up and there was something else I
did to it.
Want to do that,
you know,
so I can just go to the store.
I just have it done for you.
Well,
I'm just saying if you're really crazy
on butter,
like going old school,
make your own butter.
Have you ever tried to make your own
butter?
Oh,
I made my name.
I my mom pickles.
You dId?
Yeah.
So why?
Why is a.
Is to make your own butter.
You can't get that kind of recipe.
Oh,
the pickle recipe.
There was a place when we were filming
in boston.
I wish I remembered their name because
that would give him a shout out.
There was a fucking cart that they had
where it was all pickles and different
flavor pickles and some of them were
really spicy and some of them are really
crisp and green and some of them were
like the more sour,
like darker or lighter colored green
ones and they just had every kind of
pick on their fucking deadly and also
jesus christ.
You guys ship these pickles like I gotta
get these fucking pickles.
There were amazing.
I'll bring you something wrong.
Father mood.
Oh yeah.
One of the report the best is a bloody
mary,
but pickled asparagus and green beans in
it.
Pickled asparagus.
What do they pick lit with?
Same.
Same thing.
Same thing,
brian.
Once you have.
Once you've already made the brine,
you can use us.
Oh,
so you just stick something else in
there,
huh?
Carrots and like green cucumber.
Pickled cucumbers are good.
Do you ever have that green,
green cucumbers,
those pickled green cucumbers,
cucumbers,
tomatoes.
Those are delIcious.
It really well.
Yeah,
right there.
Chris.
You're sharp so you can like cut him
with a knife.
Yeah,
jews figured out a lot of cool shit.
She just figured out.
Pastrami.
you got to take off your fucking hat to
pastrami.
Melodrama.
We did that.
Well,
astronomy is like one of the best for
sandwiches.
Can you get them more delicious?
Meat for sandwiches.
It's fatty and they slice it real thin
and ruben's when they put the fucking
sauerkraut on that bitch and then the.
The dressing.
you guys want to go to jerry's deli.
The eat right now.
That was the hardest.
That was the hardest thing when I took
my po population.
There was one time I got green in my
home.
I got an astronomy,
have pastrami,
half chop liver,
and I was like,
I should be smoking a joint right now.
YeAh.
This is how this should go.
That will definitely enhance the food.
People don't realize how much it does
enhance how not far at all.
Real close.
Let's do the um,
what was I gonna say?
Oh,
qantas is the best.
If You want to really get down and dirty
with your pastrami,
that's the best pastrami in la.
CAnters is.
That's the oldest school.
Old school place in la.
How long has that deli been there?
A long time.
That's as exactly the same.
Yeah.
If you go into that place that's exactly
the same as it was in like the 19
seventies old pictures from the.
Yeah,
it's a,
that's the way older than that.
Yeah,
way older than that,
but I'm saying I don't think they've
done any renovations since the seventies
or maybe it might even be the fifties
pickles when you sit down and play.
Awesome.
And the food is super legit,
especially in astronomy and the white
fish to smoked white fish.
God damn,
I'm getting hungry bitches.
So to wrap things up,
can you say this before we go tell
people you can say whatever you want and
minneapolis the 25th of having a
whiskey,
throw the battleship around and then I
think me and christ are gonna.
Do a show with russell and in toronto.
Oh really?
I think.
Yeah,
they're working on.
But they have like a festival there.
Russell's february,
toronto.
He's,
that's where he's out there.
Dude.
Russell dominates up there.
What a nice guy.
Russell peters,
if you don't know,
you don't know.
Russell peters.
What a fucking great guy.
He is.
He's so friendly,
you know,
and I was like such an easy down to
earth guy.
No like airs about them.
No bullshit.
I always forget that.
He's like huge superstar.
I forget.
We were talking with him and for him
we're talking at the improv is like,
honestly,
I'm going to go on and it's like you
can't just go,
oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
You can't just go on.
I forgot who you are.
Just a regular dude.
Yeah.
Well what's really crazy is how a,
he's a huge other countries in the uk.
He sold out the o two arena,
like two nights in a row and Canada two
nights in a row.
Jesus,
that's insane.
The o two arena is what we do.
The ufc,
it's huge.
I don't know how many it is.
It's more than 50,000
like that.
I don't know.
It's more than 15,000
though.
Jesus fucking gigantic,
man.
I can't even imagine doing the chicago
theater.
It's like 3000.
Really?
Yeah.
That's pretty good.
Over the summer.
That was pretty nuts.
Yeah.
3,000
people.
A lot of people laughing when the labs
come in.
It's a boom and it's like,
wow.
It's not.
It's,
it's a weird thing man.
When you go,
when you,
whenever you go over 500,
like the laughs are bigger,
but the connection is different.
It's like it's hard to like keep that
real intimate connection with pete.
Hell myself.
This last time I was able to get a
little better because I was like slow
between jokes on.
One's a lot longer,
but usually it's like it takes me 10
minutes to like remember that.
Do you feel like it goes smoother when
you pause longer?
Like what is it?
It allows them time to take it in.
He needs more time because it's more
people bigger.
They all like when you're bouncing off
the wall and the belly room laughs.
It's like 80 people and those small
small rooms that place in boston that
upstairs my chinese place.
It was like they all hear each other and
react immediately.
Well also I think that the,
the,
the rooms,
acoustics are different.
The way you process sound is different
when there's so much loudness around you
with laughter and then this,
this is projected from speakers at a
fall.
I mean it,
that's a tricky thing and you can't
really see the guy really well so you
can't get the facial expressions,
the little non written cues like it's
time to laugh.
Yeah.
That's when comedy gets weIrd.
When you have like giant screens where
your face is on these giant screens,
man,
you'd have to.
You can't.
No one can see you if you do something
that big.
Well dane would do those big places like
that,
but he would do it in round.
He would do them in the rounds.
They'd have to have somebody in on the
screen.
They'd have to.
You have to because otherwise you're
looking at his ass,
you know,
which some girls would love started.
He hasn't done comedy and like a year I,
it's very word.
I see.
I'm just going to do an ice house
current close too soon show.
Maybe.
Maybe he will.
Maybe he'll just do the podcast part
though.
Some people still just fucking tired of
this show and he's like,
keep asking me,
but no,
I'm not back yet.
That's funny.
Yeah,
he's going to take more than a year off.
I wonder what he's doing.
You know what?
Some people are just not happy with what
they're doing.
This is what I heard that it was like
slang pussies sold out like 15,000
seaters,
whatever.
It's like,
that's,
that's the top of what you're supposed
to do.
And I was like,
what am I supposed to go?
just keep doing that.
There's nowhere else to go or she,
you know,
strongly for.
maybe that could be it or he's just
like,
we all strive to get bigger followings,
but it's like,
I got it.
I've got the biggest following and get.
Well,
his following definitely dropped off
though.
I know I talked to people that worked in
places that where he was at where he had
been there a couple of years before and
sold 15,000
seats and then he came back and sold
like seven.
It wasn't him was still huge,
but it wasn't.
It wasn't what it was at the peak of its
popularity.
It's also a lot of negativity.
He dealt with a lot of people that were
not just warranted but even unwarranted
negativity.
There's a lot of people that hated that
guy.
Yeah.
You know,
there was,
there was warranted stuff like the
plagiarism stuff that was,
you know,
it was kind of questionable it.
Well,
I shouldn't say questionable,
but it was a thought.
Yeah,
he probably stopped.
He's stopped doing that for sure.
But it was also.
I mean,
the way it all went down,
it was very unfortunate for him.
It was,
it looked horrible.
You know,
when,
when people were playing the louis ck
beds next to his bits and just became,
sort of watch them on louis' show.
Yes,
same.
Yeah.
I didn't,
I thought that was weird,
you know,
I think I like the way louis like kinda
like let them win because that's a,
that's in line with how lily would deal
with the situation.
That made sense to me.
Like,
oh yeah,
of course is how louis did it,
you know,
louisa nice guy,
and he sort of felt bad that everybody
was going after dane,
but you know,
it was what,
it was just weird.
It's just hard for god to recover from
something like that.
You know,
when,
when you get,
when you get a label put on you and you
get a lot of people that just decided to
hate you,
you know,
I'm in zach galifianakis galifianakis.
He had a member,
he used to do it on him.
I remember he used to do a bit,
well he would have pull out posters at
the end and he write things on them and
one of them was killed.
Dane cook got a huge laugh,
you know,
it's like,
it was like,
it's all sort of agree with can make
this job.
It was all he.
He became that guy like even though a
lot of people loved them,
he became the guy that a lot of people
fucking hate it and you were clear.
We're in the clear to be able to say
whatever you want it.
If you're not doing standup,
you really not in that world anymore.
You're not
attached to those people anymore.
You're not feeling their hate anymore.
You're not,
you know,
like whatever.
And now you don't.
Now you have no effect on me.
You know,
now you have no effect on me.
I'm not doing standup right now.
You have no effect on me.
Yeah,
I mean,
if you're tired of people,
just the snarky critic who is just on
instinct and you know,
on just a by default they're cunty.
You know,
there's a Lot of people like that,
but by default looking for something
shitty to say.
And when you got a target like kim
kardashians or dane cook,
when he was,
you know,
when people were shitting on him or
anybody who's in the news that you is
like a free shot,
you automatically go after them.
He's going to be a lot of people that
go,
yeah,
justin bieber,
so he's going to be someone comedy would
would help that?
Yeah,
because you're not connected to them
anymore.
You're not doIng anything and he's got
enough money.
I'm sure that he could just kick back
and relax for a few years so it doesn't
seem like a nutty spender.
So if he can just kick back and relax
for a few years and maybe while he's
doing that,
he's writing some stuff that he really
likes.
He filmed with three movies last year,
so that could also be white.
Took a year off.
That could be too.
I know like what beck did an album or a
really great album called Sea change is
all about his relationship with the
underwriter.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And he Said though,
he was like,
I couldn't write it for like two years
until after we broke up for like a
couple of years and then I was able to
like process my feelings about it and
then write this amazing work.
How's wynonna feel about it?
I don't know.
They tried to reach her,
but she was too busy stealing shit.
It's a really great album.
It's a good breakup album.
He's a scientologist isn't a
scientologist show because one's really.
What was that?
It was the knitting factory,
but it was.
It was a fundraiser for scientology and
my psychologist friend coming in.
Wow.
You have a scientologist friend.
Bobby used to have a girlfriend was
scientologist.
Okay,
so you're sitting there with all you
scientologists in you and bobby.
Wow.
He must have been there too once he
wasn't available that day and so back
is doing a show and go like fucking
scientology rule.
We didn't really talk about it.
When you see a car accident you have to
pull over because you're a scientologist
and you're the only one that's going to
know what time.
Well,
it could help.
I just think it'd be too bad if you
like.
Dane cook.
Is that the way he talks about comedy
and the way he like.
He's been 20 years in the game to lose a
pro.
Like a professional man.
It's too bad it doesn't.
Well,
who knows if he's losing it,
maybe he's just taken a year off,
you know,
maybe he just.
Seriously,
he is on a tv show.
He never took time off.
Nobody.
There's a big difference between doing
all these movies and.
Yeah.
And taking time off of standup.
Not coming up with a new album,
doing any standup in la guys take two
weeks off and it's a big deal.
You know,
two weeks is kind of shaky.
You come back,
you're a little,
you know,
you got to do like one set of week.
Well I got,
I got tuesday,
wednesday this week at the store.
They're going to be gone in Brazil for
the rest.
I only got,
that's what I called him for it.
I only got one spot and I was like,
no,
I'm not gonna be able to get along until
tuesday.
I had to call my [inaudible] is on the
book cover now you got to let me slide
in.
Oh,
okay.
You use your a while,
but not once in a while.
Only when you need to though.
I'm saying there's no way.
You go off like a year with nothing.
Who's making that fucking list at the
comedy store?
It's fine.
Not to get me one day out of the way.
Silly fucks.
I'm running a new hour this year.
oh yeah?
Yeah.
Are you throwing your old one out?
What are you doing?
Done chuck and done.
Did you make a dvd or a cd?
Can make a dvd son.
Can't throw Your material out without a
fucking visual representation of it.
Yeah.
A lot of your Shit is visual.
Maybe get some of the.
Hire someone film you cheap prick.
I might make a special.
Put it on line.
Release it to people.
Yeah.
Give it to the world already.
Make a video like a video.
A video.
Dude.
You can't just have an audio.
My first cd was there.
I was upset that some of my shit wasn't
visual.
So videos of it and release them to put
it online after the fact.
Yeah.
There's a lot of shit like the um,
the old lady vagina bit.
That's,
that's a lot of visual in that boom.
You know,
I don't remember there at the bottom.
Boom.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's visual.
You need that part.
That's a big part of why it's funny with
the party tonight,
which is what happens when a woman's
vagina and she gets it.
yeah.
Yeah.
Don't say anymore.
There was a kid that would be a little
visual.
Very,
very visual.
Yeah.
The fuck ari.
So people want to see your work in the
see arch for this upcoming minneapolis
show.
Where is it?
at?
A house academy.net
house of comedy.net.
And you'll be in chicago the same time?
Yes.
I will be in chicago.
The 27th.
Is it that weekend?
Twenty fifth is my ninth.
Yeah,
I'm going to be in there.
Still some tickets available,
but they're going fast pitches.
Joey diaz and duncan trussell.
We're going to be at the chicago theater
on January 27th and if you see joey
onstage,
joey will probably be not walking so
good because he's just going to have
surgery 10 days before that.
It's gonna.
Get one of those scooters.
Scooters.
But because if anybody wants to get them
some flowers and say get well cards,
get well.
Joey flowers.
Give me the,
can I get out of here with this fucking
cards and flowers.
Just giving him a lot that gave me an
envelope of cash in it or nothing.
Um,
so yeah,
so joey will be there supposedly.
I hope he's going to be able to make it,
but he's getting surgery 10 days before.
Yeah,
pretty tight.
Tight scheduling.
Dunkin's going to be there for sure.
I'll be there.
And then there's the ufc on fox is the
next day.
You can see that.
Or if you are closer to my man already
should fear you go to minneapolis and go
to the house of comedy.net.
How's a comedy.net?
And it will be that weekend.
How many days you there?
Five days.
Damn.
That's nice.
That's time for a relationship.
You could meet a new girl and fall in
love and then totally hate each other by
the 27th roles.
We're at the nexus of it.
Exactly.
Boom.
Thank you to the fleshlight for
sponsoring our podcast.
If you go to joe rogan.net
and click on the link for the flashlight
entering the code named brogan,
you will get 15 percent off the number
one sex from man.
Oh shit.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot com,
o n n I t,
makers of alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement,
new mood shroom,
tech,
sport and shroom tech immune.
Go to the link on joe rogan.net.
Click on it for the lake for alpha
brain.
Entering the code name,
rogan,
and you can get 10 percent off.
All right,
thanks everybody.
Next Week we have hamilton morris from
vice.com.
We're going to be going on an isolation
tank tour.
We're going to go to venice.
Yeah,
and we're going to.
he's going to come on the podcast as
well and I've got steven rinella from.
What's that show called?
The wild within,
which was a really cool show that got
canceled.
Now I think he's got a new show called
mediator.
So he's going to be on the podcast on
monday.
Yeah,
that's cool.
Alright.
Dirty freaks of welfare.
Me.
Yeah.
Brian is fucking silly.
Internet contest.
He wants everybody to vote for him,
for the wind.
Just got a desk squad that tv and at the
top It says,
vote for me to just click on that.
That'd be awesome and I'll be at wider
bits and stuff.
Thursday waterbeds and stuff you do
doing shows that.
Waterbed factories.
Now I'm just going to.
What does water beds and it's the only
place to buy a bull in columbus,
Ohio.
to buy a bowl.
Yeah.
They said waterbeds and pipes and that's
where you're going to be.
They all lIstened to this podcast.
Want to show them that way?
They're not just going to buy a book.
Don't be scared.
homey.com.
Thanks everybody.
Oh,
one more thought.
I interviewed a hooker on my podcast
with tim.
It's real one class prostitute.
Really?
Ooh.
How do people get that?
Go to itunes or my website or the grades
are the grades.com.
It was a good conversation.
He told me everything.
Oh my god.
Ooh.
I might listen to that.
It was really fun.
I'm listening to that on the flight to
Brazil,
the five other things.
It's a long flight.
yeah.
Yeah.
All right,
you fucking freaks are nice.
We love you guys.
love everybody.
We'll see you next week.
Thanks sam.
Thanks for everybody.
Thanks for thanks for everything.
Thanks to everybody for everything.
I've been talking too much today
anymore.
Jihad.